[Music]
humming without in on your wrist so it's
acara so I mean it's like heritage
there's you know different articles that
people rock and aha
the gutta historically they'd wear
multiple you know going right battle it
served as a weapon protection and
everything else and then from a
spiritual context I mean it all depends
on who you ask is right everyone has
their own context for it but I've been
told when I was a kid it was you're
handcuffed to the divine I was also told
it was your reminder to be self-aware
I've also been told it's the source of
iron because it's made out of iron so
just rubbing in your skin it's a
reminder of infinity because it's a
circle no beginning no end like creation
is that specific to the Sikh tradition
yeah yeah yeah it's part of the so
normally it's usually what most people
you know it's kind of come the cross
right census it's just like but why only
one I used to rock a whole bunch I mean
I started making a lot of noise yeah and
then I used to have one on this time as
well dan I think when I first got a
tattoo I think I took it off just for
the healing and then I went back on
after that well listen man really
excited to have you here today
feel so grateful of you man delighted to
meet you been following your stuff for a
long time and and you're somebody you're
just one of those people that is kind of
out in the ether and I'd see your stuff
from time to time and I'm like that
guy's cool man like he's like rocking
like an awesome vibe and kind of made a
mental note like he'd be awesome for the
podcast but for whatever reason like I
just didn't I didn't know you or I
didn't I wasn't I mean our friends
circles like overlap but we know tons of
the same people but that only got
revealed after we connected yeah I know
right like oh you know so so I don't
know so I think it was well it was Neil
Pasricha who basically then connected
the dots for us he's a good friend of
mine who I ran into on at the airport or
something yeah we used to be ended up
sitting beside each other on the plane
and I just like oh you need to talk to
rich yeah he said well I want to get
Neil on the show too amazing author yeah
and then just the other day you shared
our mutual friend Utkarsh
little clip of him like on stage at Ted
live with freestyle Love Supreme
yes so I I checked
did it cars yesterday and I was like
come on man you got to come over like
humbles coming over he wanted to come
and hang out but he had to work this
afternoon okay but he's the best man we
were like five or six years okay and
he's been on the podcast we just met at
Ted oh you did oh so you were there were
you there in an official capacity where
you did you give a talk or I didn't give
a talk I went there as a guest and
trying to figure out how to you know
stand beside the stage and see if they
let me on and spontaneously
yeah just one of the speakers just
wasn't cutting in they just grabbed a
hook and just hooked them on stage and I
would just run on and really hey guys
right this is my impromptu TED talk so I
was hoping for that to happen didn't
happen but uh I think it's just me I am
obsessed with learning communities so
whether it's TED Talks Google zeitgeist
any I think world domination summit it's
gonna be the next one at ten just any
anything in anywhere where just people
are open to learning new stuff and I can
just sit there and just have my biases
challenged here an idea I haven't heard
before so I tried it I try to wiggle my
way into all of this so this is my
second year at Ted and cool
I had a mutual friend with question and
like hey yeah it'd take his number yet
to find him when you're there yeah and
then we hit it off he's the dick man
he's super talented
and world domination summit I spoke at
that event a couple years ago it's
pretty cool like in the world of kind of
like big conferences and the like like
Chris really runs an amazing show yeah
you'll enjoy that but I'm surprised you
haven't done a TED talk I've been
invited to a couple of Ted exes and I
think just trying to wrap my head around
how the culture works and I think
understanding as well it's in addition
to my own personal ambitions what it
represents for me having a turbot in the
beard wiggling my way slowly into the
mainstream ethos and and and how I need
to kind of navigate that so I've been
really trying to figure out the best way
to make that happen and have an impact
and learn the I guess the subtle nuances
of that community and what they're
looking for because apparently it's not
just as straightforward as hey let me
just do a TED talk and it just give you
20 minutes it's like it's a little bit
more curated than I thought so I think
I'm learning about that I applied to be
a fellow last year I didn't make it and
apply again this year and see what
happens well on that subject of
of being conscious of your roots and you
know your your heritage your ethnicity
and your heritage and all of that like
how conscious are you of that in the
process of you know creating the art
that you create like is that a is it is
I guess what I'm getting at is sort of
like you are who you are and your
ethnicity doesn't it permeates what you
do but it's not the sort of top line
subject matter like in a very you know
Express way does that make sense
I insert very articulately but you know
it's it is who you are and it's the
ethos behind like everything that you
express yeah and your sensibility but
it's not like this is you don't you're
not using it as a weapon I guess yeah
definitely not I'm not I mean I feel
like the times have continually changed
to kind of make that happen by itself I
think having Donald Trump as president
definitely threw me into a whole
different direction as people started to
view me superficially as oh this would
be a great guy to put front and center
this man represents everything that
we're trying to promote to fight that
certain energy and me being cognizant of
that and being like look I don't want to
just simply become the benefactor of
reverse racism now because all of a
sudden everyone's looking for
quote-unquote diversity and inclusion
you know I do substance to what I'm
trying to put out there but I think what
else start to realize is now kind of
being in my 10th year as an artist
starting to actually see the cultural
impact of my existence from my community
which I wasn't thinking about when I
first started I was just a guy with
personal ambitions trying to make it in
music trying to you know impress a
couple girls and have fun and now 10
years later meeting artists and coming
across other creatives and then giving
me very specific stories about all when
you made that song when you wrote that
post or when you first released this
book how it impacted me and changed
stuff and starting to see it in the way
you know people are tying turbans the
way I tie it I met I met a kid in New
York that had copied some of my tattoos
hmm there's a guy in India that has my
face tattooed on his next we start to
realize like there's an impact there
and I was heavily influenced by hip-hop
culture that's what helped me find my
foundation in my self-confidence so now
being more mindful of it not trying to
assume some role model role or
ambassador role but moreso being like
hey this is an opportunity because 15
years ago when people thought turban and
beard they thought enemy combatant and
they thought terrorists they thought
certain things and now it's an
opportunity where I might not be able to
do anything with the older generation
but you know kids are growing up and if
humble the poet's their point of
reference then I think that's something
very healthy yeah I would imagine as
inspiring as that can be for you and as
energizing it can be for your art it
also poses the risk or the danger of
causing you to get too much in your head
and get overly calculated about what
you're doing you know what I mean like
there's a purity in your expression and
once that becomes not contaminated
that's the wrong word but kind of
influenced by those externalities the do
you concern yourself with like well if I
if I start to think like well there's
that kid in India and I need to appeal
to him or it needs to hit these sort of
demographics then you're sort of losing
the thread of what makes you you know
you yeah absolutely whenever anything
works whatever I put something out and
it works and that gets stuck in your
head and you're that little voice in
your head like you should do more of
this you know whether you know the first
time I ever released that past a million
views on YouTube all of a sudden you're
like oh I should make more of that even
if it was a happy accident that's my
personal you know challenges that I've
enthusiastically approached was like hey
I have to be more free thinking I have
to let go I have to be less analytical
and less strategic and be more of a
creative and an artist I also kind of
feel like I see what the energies are
headed and things are really kind of
heading in the direction I wanted them
to head so when I first published on
learned I had swearing in it when I
independently published it and that
wasn't something too too common and then
working with my first publisher in
Canada you know they were trying to
double down on the swearing and they
wanted to change the title to put
scoring on it and you're like whoa this
is a lot different than when I
resistance I first got so I feel like
the the authenticity authenticity is
what people are hungry for it just
becomes a challenge when people are
manufacturing their authenticity
authenticity has been co-opted and now
it's manufactured yeah I I think for me
from my mental health I realized that I
have to focus on paying attention not
getting attention because getting
attention is this peak lowest mountain
that I can continually chase and now
it's like oh look at these beautiful
flowers oh let me take a picture beside
these beautiful flowers to document them
oh these beautiful flowers didn't give
me the likes I wanted to get and I think
I realized for me it was like no you
know what instead pay attention to what
you're putting out there and now
challenge yourself to outdo your own
work from a craft perspective so it's
like okay I wrote that oh I had to
edited that because I didn't want my mom
to read that story about myself well now
that's what I have to lean into that
discomfort in that fear or hey people
might misinterpret these words and get
offended well you know what let it
happen you know to be a free thinker you
you have to run the risk of offending
some people and I think for me I've been
focusing a lot more on that in the craft
and I mean I'm very fortunate to be one
of the only one of the few people on
Instagram that doesn't have to post
pictures of himself to have a loyal
follower ship meaning you're you share
your words so my words assure my words
and I got plenty of you on there though
there's a couple pictures there's some
like someone's taking a picture of me in
the night and they send it to me than
and it looks okay then I can definitely
close by it's kind of that that jay
Shetty formula of like quote image quote
you know mix it up a little bit yeah the
grid yeah yeah the Wellness grid yes is
that what it is at that term for that
well I'm Duncan coining it now yeah it's
been a few and wellness you better get
on that grid or I don't know that just
makes me want to go in the other
direction yeah but in the then you had
to ask yourself that question right
which is like why do I not want why do I
need to be different for this and when I
was an elementary school teacher that
was one thing that really put in my head
which was stop trying to reinvent the
wheel and write I thought you had the
counterbalance that against there's this
formula out here and this is what works
and if you want to you know be seen in
this way this is what
you do and as an artist isn't it your
job to question that and to deconstruct
that and and and say well what is my own
personal way completely completely and I
know for me like when I started to see a
lot of those videos which was like you
know if you're heartbroken you need to
watch this or you know or or they know
how much I needed to see this until I
woke up yeah those things you're like
really gory yeah a little bit click baby
and it's also kind of like it turns in
that and i'm i'm also an influencer so i
work with brands and i work with
agencies and then they send you these
white papers that give you all the tips
and tricks to like ensure you have
maximum engagement and yeah and then all
of a sudden you start to get these
little tips as well and I guess as that
non-stop balancing act of trying to be
like okay well I'm existing in this
attention economy and you know we're
kind of governed by these Greek gods
known as the algorithms who don't care
how dope our words are they just care
about are we feeding them content
content content and in deciding to
yourself okay how much of this matters
because there's a never-ending journey
yeah and you're never gonna have enough
the word enough doesn't exist in that
space and I think for me the question is
just been like are you having fun and
figuring it out so for me I've been able
to kind of participate in that world but
kind of working with other people I can
have an assistant now so now when I
write my content is an email I'm taking
a quote I'm taking an idea I type it out
email I hit Send I don't get any
immediate gratification because it
doesn't go up maybe for like two weeks
uh-huh so I don't get any gratification
knowing at people like so it goes into
some queue and your assistant puts it
together and post it for you
it goes into a queue and my assistant
just make sure there's no spelling
mistakes haha she makes sure I didn't
like repeat the same word too many times
and then she ensures that the grid stays
the grid Wow
how do you how do you balance the the
commerce aspect of what you do with the
creative aspect I think now as of lately
taking this as my responsibility and not
it's something I want to do and hope
people will allow me to do realizing
that hey I'm like I don't know how to
swim I love to dance but I'm not a good
dancer
you know I love to sing and I got a
decent singing voice but when I put
words together it helps people
understand their own stories this is my
responsibility this is how I contribute
to this grand scheme and from that you
need resources and if you find ways to
get those resources it'll help you
amplify this and I live a super simple
life I don't own a car I float around I
don't really you know buy clothes I make
my own stuff and yeah people give me
stuff so it's like I kind of know my
struggling artist days which was a solid
five years really made me an involuntary
minimalist mhm and I haven't let that go
now that my bank accounts in it well
there's a freedom with that yes you
realize you don't need all of these
things you're you're liberated from that
and if you can kind of maintain that
that sensibility it just opens up doors
and possibilities for you because you're
not constrained by your material
relationships exactly and it's kind of
like now how am I going to use these
resources to either amplify the message
of further this or take six months off
and isolate myself and work on something
and a new idea I heard recently was you
know go somewhere where your ego has
nothing to do you know go places where
you know your ego does not have an
opportunity to shine and do something
and that's by yourself where no one's
watching and now all of a sudden once
your ego decides to take a nap because
it's nothing there for it to do you can
start that journey of self-discovery and
being you know being a realist and
focusing on pragmatism that requires
resources as well right but it's also
your obligation and your responsibility
as an artist you need that solitude that
reflection and that ability to distance
yourself from culture and kind of the
gestalt of society in order to have
perspective yeah sure well it was Neal
that shared me with it one of his great
ideas is he devotes two days a week to
just spending going on long five-hour
walk I know that's what he does like I'm
like I don't know how he does
like he'll send me these long texts and
I'm like I don't have time to respond to
this but he seems to have a lot of time
and he's unbelievably productive like
you got these books and he's like I was
walking through Toronto today and I have
this amazing conversation with a
shopkeeper and I was like this is not
my life you know he's efficient
beautiful yeah yeah I'm fishing he's
efficient was the way it's not like ya
know he's living he's some single dude
yeah he's got three kids and he's and
he's earning money and he's working and
but he set it up in a way where he he
sees the value in these two days a week
and right he makes it happen and and
that makes his work better that makes it
work so much better yeah and I think so
I'm taking a lot of cues from him and
other artists that I'm seeing who have
doubled down on the craft more so than
to pursuit of attention and kind of
playing the popularity game because very
quickly this can just become a bigger
example of middle school where
everyone's just chasing for attention
and it's not only exhausting it's
unsustainable and ultimately it works at
cross-purposes with the ultimate like if
your goal is to really create a legacy
and have impact you're just burning
yourself out in order to really create
something of lasting import you need
that time away and that reflection that
we were talking about completely and you
need three days just to let go of some
of those inner bullies in your head
they're just saying a bunch of stuff
like no you got to make this a hit you
got to get a New York Times best seller
list you got a you got to prove that
person who didn't return your text wrong
like now they're gonna feel bad when
they see you want Jimmy Kimmel like but
you're just a ping-pong ball reacting to
your environment exactly but I know and
I say that as somebody who does that
yeah I'm not saying that I've exempted
myself from that oh and I think we're
all guilty of it I think that's where it
just takes time for these voices to
subside and it's been I become very
cognizant of the people I hang out with
now because in the beginning you know
very superficially people like Walt
don't be around naked if people say all
right I'm not around negative people
well also you know be around people who
was purpose and who are productively all
right cool some of my sweet nice friends
that aren't really doing much with their
existence I'm gonna spend less time
around not that I don't like them I just
need to feed off the energy of others
now I'm around you know
ambitious productive people but now
amongst them some of them are a little
bit too caught up in the game and I was
like oh this is this is rubbing off on
me because now they're making me think
about things that I was never thinking
about they're making me self-conscious
about things I never thought about you
know
had friends worried about being seen
sitting in coach on an airplane or
friends talking about oh we got a oh
we're going to this event oh we got a we
got to get the who were black like why
can't we just go through brakes no not
not this one dad they can't see this and
I was like okay there's nothing wrong
with this person but they're getting
lost in sauce I have to find people who
might not be doing that as much and I
have to kind of control my dosage
accordingly and it's just it's a never
is always levels to this and always
being cognizant of it and it does lead
back to just much more a long time which
so many people avoid because they don't
have that relationship with themselves
yeah well I think it it I have a little
bit of a countervailing opinion on that
which is that your ability to kind of
navigate those different types of people
in those circles is contingent upon your
spiritual fitness if you have a porous
boundary and you're around negative
people or people whose priorities are at
odds with your own then yeah that's
gonna seep into your you know
consciousness and impact your behavior
but if you're like a Jedi Master you can
go anywhere it doesn't matter and every
person that you see or you encounter is
a learning experience a mirror to help
you reflect on your own behavior and
kind of sharpen the sword of what's most
important to you and how we how to how
do we approach Jedi Master and from your
experience I don't know I was gonna ask
you that question man I feel like the
way I always look at it we the longer my
mom we saw we say you know you don't
have to be in the fire to get burnt you
still feel the heat and you know be
mindful of your company and we can we
have an idea called summit which is the
congregation and they always talk about
satsang it's not being true being when
the true congregation my mom always
looked at as be around people in the
temple who are praying and worshipping I
took it more holistically and being like
you are a product of your environment no
matter where you are if I spend more
time in New York I'll probably pick up
the accident yeah so I guess for me my
boundaries may be rigid and then slowly
they become more porous and slowly get
to get chipped away at until I realized
that and I think
Bojack horseman said it
it's like the LA Tar Pits is a big
analogy for the whole city is that you
stand in one place long enough you
slowly sink in without realizing so
that's why I've been doing the 50-50 the
moment I catch myself saying something
the moment I catch myself describing a
dilemma as a problem mm-hmm and I have
to go home
mmm you know and that's what I see out
here because when I go home then I
encounter people with real problems yeah
whether it's health issues whether it's
you know dealing with certain traumas or
what-have-you and out here sometimes
people are like oh this person didn't
acknowledge me enough and yeah they're
losing this stuff over that or this girl
then takes me back and was like okay if
I start to validate these is problems
get out I need to get out I need to go
back to some of the realness and just
hang out with my high school buddies
Ellie it's very weird that way
and it's an easy target it's an easy you
know destination for a takedown on all
of those you know for all of those
reasons which are all valid yeah you
know I found that as somebody's lived
here for a very long time that there's a
lot of beauty here too that gets
overlooked I think you just you have to
be a lot more intentional yes about what
you're doing you go to New York life
happens it's right in front of you you
can't escape it you fall into the flow
of you know whatever's happening just by
virtue of being present there yeah but
here you'll just be it's it's easy to be
incredibly lonely here and it's easy to
fall in with a crowd that you don't
resonate with you have to really spend
enough time here to figure out where are
my people where's the place that I like
to hang out and seek those people out
and exert a lot more energy and effort
to cultivate that community and it takes
a lot longer
yeah completely and I think people out
here have really forced me to ask myself
the question what are my priorities I
think all relationships depend on
priorities lining up and the challenge
is a you know if I want to have a
relationship with you whether it's
business whether it's friendship whether
it's romantic I have to know what your
priorities are after know what my
priorities are and see if they line up
and that is the whole dance just trying
to figure out what's really important to
you and that might not come out through
your words that might only come through
your actions and then doing the work
myself to figure out what's really
important to me
and I think coming out here that that
was one of the big challenges because it
was a situation where my I came out here
as a struggling artist I came out here
with with not much promise to everything
I was working on not picking up any
traction and then kind of like like it's
like a chicken without his head just
running in any direction when I saw
something working for somebody else oh
this person was dropping a video every
other day I should just drop videos
every other day oh this person's getting
involved in this type of process should
do that and then having to stop back and
being like is this you do you want to do
this for the next 10 years the next 20
years are you just trying to do this now
because you feel like you need to make a
quick buck and that's when taking that
step back slowing down and they're
really paying attention to the people
that was around and be like oh well this
person is doing very well but they
they're doing something that was fun for
them eight years ago and it's not fun
for them anymore but their audience
won't let them do anything else right
and now become a prisoner of their own
sort of system that they set up for
themselves exactly and then I realized
that's more important than adding
another comma to my net worth that's
more important than getting recognized
by peers or acknowledgement by you know
some awards show and that really started
the journey for me and now and I got
dropped off here about my book age and I
had said if it listen now everything I'm
gonna say to you comes from the idea
that I want to have fun and you know I
this is the first time I released a book
with a major publisher and some things
were completely amazing something for
you know banging my head against the
wall and being like if this is not gonna
be fun then we're gonna have to explore
different routes and and these are the
ideas I think that will make this more
of an enjoyable collaborative
opportunity and none of these involve
getting a bigger advance these involve
more collaboration more transparency you
know them being more open to some of my
ideas then presenting less roadblocks
when I try to do things on my own and I
think chasing the fun and a big one that
I learned after one was Jai Shetty you
know just really reminding me like screw
the pot of gold it's all about the
rainbow and if the rainbow doesn't sound
enticing then that pot of gold won't
make up for it yeah yeah yeah
I think you're seeing a lot of that in
the Creator community right now
especially with the vloggers like all
these kids that kind of came up doing
daily vlogs and you know at some point
like this is not a sustainable lifestyle
know at some point you're gonna you just
flame out on that and kind of that
moment has arrived for a lot of those
people and you can see them wrestling in
different ways with how to find the best
way forward from that still maintaining
their connection with their audience but
not being you know chained you know
indefinitely to this kind of expectation
or regular output that is just bananas
yeah because it's never-ending like you
know back in the days the first
generation of youtubers was like drop a
video once a week make you know make
some good money and I'll get some great
opportunities and then people came in
disrupted that buy job in two videos a
week and all of a sudden it's like three
videos a day and then lies are getting
better and better and better and the
rush shirt so it's just like yeah you
can chase that forever and you know but
then so then mental health becomes an
issue with a lot of these people than
they're coming out and talking about
that which is healthy obviously for the
ecosystem but but that in itself can be
turned into a remedy like oh come on a
fiying like you know all these servants
infest the confessional culture it's
crazy man yeah like this is like yeah
hey that's one let's you guys know that
I'm gonna be taking a break because of
my mental health this announcement was
brought to you by audible you know and
you'd like to feel like you know an ally
everybody has to come out with that but
uh-huh and at the same time and no it's
not all disingenuous and I'm starting to
see now where people are existing in the
space where the lines are blurred like I
had a friend pass out from like
heatstroke at a concert and he was a
larger dude and he fell on top of me and
then like I caught him but I felt with
him and then when we got him down and
everybody was really kind and then while
you know he was he was waking up one of
the first questions he asked was like
did you guys get it on camera man and I
and I don't take anything away from him
as a person I think he's a wonderful
person but I think it's the culture out
here
has kind of normalized to the point
where everything needs to be documented
and nobody questions why anymore and I
have a friend who's a model in Sydney
Australia and she came out here and
she's like oh my god is so acceptable to
just like carry your tripod around and
take pictures anywhere and like when I'm
in Sydney they look at me funny and I
was like I don't know if that's a great
it's probably a great thing if you're a
creative consultant and a stylist and
you were too scared to share your stuff
when you were in Sydney and here people
are okay with it and it's just really
trying to find that because everything
can be documented and everything can be
used as currency our vulnerability can
be currency you know if something
happened to us we can we can lean on
that and that gets people interested
people we as human beings want to hear
stories and as we should stories are
what pushes us forward it just got to a
point now or it's like okay well how can
I peppers you pepper these stories in or
add some spice in these stories to make
them more interesting and then you get
to yourself to a situation we're like
well the last story I told was amazing
what's the next one gonna be well maybe
if I can't if I don't have a story maybe
I can create a story and then I think
that's where we get to this
manufacturing of authenticity yeah it's
it's a pathology really you become you
become you really become a victim of
your own life because you're unable to
ever be present in the experience that
you're having you're always calculating
your next move when everybody is the
star of their own personal Truman Show
yes I mean really the litmus test for me
is like why am i sharing like what is
the purpose of sharing this is it
sharing it to share it or is there some
message that I'm trying to convey or
some experience that I have that could
be of benefit to other people but if I
don't run that mental calculus and
you're just doing it for the purpose of
doing it because you think that's what's
important in order to be relevant then
you've lost the plot yeah I completely
agree but I also feel like each
individual is gonna kind of have to go
do it themselves and kind of hit that
freaking point hopefully I mean I used
to you know casually take a picture of
myself in business class and try to make
it look like it wasn't about me being a
business class but me taking a selfie
but just make
you sure the audience kind of knew
because I'd get some validation from it
because in in the early years your fan
base is there celebrating you like
family and friends like oh our boy made
it or boys you know getting recognition
from the mainstream or our boys getting
paid to sell Nestle chocolates you know
in the beginning you know it was them
watching you kind of growing and me
realizing the hey is this the message I
want to put out there is this you know I
got a 14 year old nephew is this what I
want him to aspire to is these things
that matter you know getting getting to
go to the all-star game and him being
really excited because you know he's
playing basketball he's like six - you
know young kid yeah and him being like
oh man I wish I was there with you and
me realizing hey I'll be more excited
when I get to watch you play you know
and letting him know that that's more
important to me than getting to say
courtside this year and being like hey
those are the things that are gonna
matter in the long run for me and that's
the idea I want to put with you that
despite all these things that that 1% of
each of our lives that we show on
Instagram carefully curated the stuff
that really matters our relationships
the people that we connect with these
new experiences the opportunities that
we have to lean into our discomforts and
and be guided by our let our fears not
dictate our actions and we find some
growth in some validation that we can
continually evolve as people I think
these are the more exciting things but
you can't capture that in a photo
you know without kind of still sharing
this story and having the same narrative
of like you know people taking pictures
I'm so grateful to have this opportunity
to be here and it's like are we grateful
to be here are we be able to be able to
document it and give the impression that
we're grateful people well I think
there's a difference between for example
if I was to take a picture of myself
sitting courtside at the all-star game
business you I mean I saw that photo
you're like sitting next to Spike Lee
Yeah right it's like right on the court
it's the same and for a community of
young you know East Asians like that's
very impactful to see somebody who looks
like them in a situation that they you
know that they can relate to as being
embraced
by mainstream culture has you know is
sort of you know downstream impact on
how young northern Indians or six or
anybody from you know the part of world
from where you come to think differently
about their own personal potential yeah
and it eventually turns into becoming
you know children of the Diaspora where
it's just like hey my family came from
another place and they came here my
parents still think the ways of their
old country I grew up in North America
with completely different priorities I
want to do XYZ my parents want me to do
ABC and there's always this clash and
now here's a here's a guy that still you
know hangs out with his mom all the time
and she still wanted him to you know get
married have kids and be a doctor lawyer
engineer and he went and did a whole
bunch of other different stuff but
without conflict and I think that is as
I said the cultural the cultural part of
it and that core side picture to me is
no different than the grid it's giving
them something familiar something they
value and I learned that after going to
a movie premiere and the only you know
and wanting to be wanting to acknowledge
that I was I was invited to this movie
premiere and give a shout out to the
movie but the only thing that they had
the only signage they had was on a
Lamborghini so they had their so I took
a picture with the Lamborghini I don't
know huh that's not quote-unquote on
Brad for me I don't take pictures of
nice cars but the engagement blew up you
know and realizing that people like most
people they dig that stuff they dig
fancy stuff they dig pretty things they
dig shiny things and really trying to
deciding okay well how do I put the pill
in the apple sauce alright I took a
picture I was I was given a picture of
me courtside and with a bunch of very
you know influential individuals now
that's the that's the applesauce what's
the pill well let me write it in the
caption let me share my stories now let
me share stories about things that I've
experienced and now how hopefully this
can create an impact and you know
culturally show people because we're
gonna get to a point where I will I
won't be the first to do anything
anymore and for South Asians in general
we won't be celebrating the first South
Asian to get our own NBC show the first
South Asian to win an Emmy the first
South Asian to win an Oscar once we pass
that and my nieces and nephews
generation grows up
just like well we can do anything and
that's embedded in his subconscious yeah
you know the same way a young child of
color can believe they can be present
because they saw Obama so I think for me
that cultural impact is important and
that does require recognizing how these
mechanisms work whether it's considered
playing the game to change the game a
whether is considered respecting your
environment accordingly and not being
too disruptive but I think there's God
atoms that said in the beginning you
have to give them what they know before
you can give them what they need yeah
super interesting well let's take it
let's take it back so you grew up in
Toronto
born and raised yeah your parents are
Punjabi yeah your dad had an engineering
degree but it was like a cab driver he
had a master's in economics so he got a
master's degree in economics yeah came
to Canada in the early 70s and came to
Canada to get married did his their
generation didn't really have a lot of
choice in the matter of what they did
with their lives so his parents are like
you got to move out to Canada we found a
girl for you you're gonna get married
arrange something what purpose of the
move was to to have an arranged marriage
yeah so the purpose of the move was most
likely we found a girl in Canada and I
think my mother before they got married
was already in doing the paperwork to
sponsor him over and then once he was
over he'd be able to bring all his
siblings over so it was very
transactional strategic yeah right so
then he came out and then as soon as he
came out he got married and then he
started working he had to start working
immediately and I think he worked in a
factory for a bit of furniture factory
while he was taking the course to get
his taxi license and then once he got
that taxi license he drove that for the
next 30 years and your only only child
no I'm the only boy at - yeah so you
grew up with that sort of educational
pressure expectation engineer doctor
lawyer this is gonna be the path for you
that that's the path it was a very often
my father would always say as long as
you're in school you don't have to worry
about anything you would always say that
you don't have to worry about money you
don't worry about whatever you need I
will give you as long as you're in
school and he was saying this to me when
I was like eight selves I was thinking
about like pizza lunches and stuff like
that really good student I was a very
good student but I wasn't a hard-working
student it was just I had the in just
different we all have different learning
abilities and learning styles so I'm a
I'm an auditory learner and a visual
learner so I can see and learn and I can
hear it and learn most most people who
struggle in traditional schools are
kinesthetic they need to have an
opportunity to work with things and
manipulate things which isn't always
available in the classroom so I was
doing very well all the way up through
high school but not really working hard
yeah hard until I hit university and
university requires a little bit more
effort than simply brains and that's
when I started to see that I had to step
up my work ethic but yeah I did very
well in school got into university did a
degree in IT coding when all that's
right so then how do you end up becoming
an elementary school teacher so at that
point it was like hey let me just do
what was what there's one one guy in our
family or a family friend he went and
did an undergrad and did an MBA and got
a job at Nike and then got a job at Ford
and really go that's how you get a job
like you know he said so I was gonna
take that NBA route and it was actually
watching that television show Boston
Public and and seeing you know as a TV
show about a high school in Boston and
just watching one of the episodes and
being like whoa this is so cool it must
be so cool to be a teacher and I was
always attending youth camps since I was
a kid you know camps inspired by sick
History sick philosophy and just kind of
what you learned how to read Punjabi
whether you learn the history what you
learned how to sing hymns and they were
fun there was like you know 30% class
80% going canoeing skating skiing so I
was like there are fun things I grew up
in them and then I used to volunteer for
them so like by 1617 I was already a
counselor like a counselor it's not a
lot of experience with kids and I had a
really good repertoire so my sister that
said it she was want to become a teacher
she was you actually good with kids and
you probably had more fun than trying to
get your MBA and then I didn't know
anything about it and I
if through mutual friends found somebody
who was a teacher he kind of schooled me
to the well this is what you're gonna
have to do to become a teacher
applying to Teachers College it's going
through the whole process forged a bunch
of volunteer hours to get it cuz it was
like two months before the before the
application process and then I got in I
got in to York University's teachers
program and which is a very difficult
one to get into I didn't know how
difficult it was to get in I do suspect
a little bit of reverse racism help me
there as well because they started to
recognize representation mattered and
then yeah went to Teachers College
finished that got hired right before I
graduated in elementary school and
taught the 4th grade for a couple years
in the fifth grade and in the third
grade before I left Wow
so how many years did you do that five
years yeah no those are really
interesting ages they are interesting
aids and it taught me a lot taught me a
lot about how to communicate it taught
me a lot about my own biases because I
started to realize that these kids are
like literally empty vessels uh-huh at
that point whenever they say anything
remotely critical or ugly you can hear
they're just parroting the parent right
exactly and that really made me start to
question like whoa how much of me is me
and how much of me is what other people
taught me how much of me is my
neighborhood how much of me is the media
and that's kind of the premise behind
unlearn was right those are the initial
seeds behind that that were planted that
birth unlearn yeah because once I had
left and I had left assuming I got a
record deal so I was like okay um you
know I was alright let's slow down here
alright yeah I mean the first question I
have is when did you have were you a kid
who is making music all along and kind
of repressing this artistic sensibility
that you have because you felt like it
didn't fit you know familial
expectations or was it something you
kind of discovered in yourself later in
life no I was I was definitely a kid who
was writing stories that was the kid who
was writing music in my head but
definitely Saturday morning TV shows
Nickelodeon Disney Channel none of the
kids look like me so that was enough for
me it just never felt like it could be a
possibility yeah like I didn't see
myself on home
I didn't see myself on Mickey Mouse Club
I didn't see myself on any of these TV
shows I was like this is the stream is
not available yeah this is not what
people see just it down pushed it down
and stayed to the what was more
quote/unquote realistic and then what
ended up happening was when I started
working I you know in your evenings you
had a lot more free time you don't have
homework so I was I took a second job as
a high school math tutor I was really
good at math I'm still pretty good at
math so I was tutoring kids at high
school kids in math for extra cash
trying to you know live a life beyond
what teachers were getting paid and I'd
be going out to concerts going out to
shows just doing whatever I could to
just you know be social enjoy life and I
saw a spoken-word artists perform and I
had never seen that before and then that
was the time that I realized I started
digging into spoken word poetry
realizing that hey these guys this is a
reaction to how boring people think
poetry is like you pick up a book of
poetry and you're like this is very
bland and in realizing because you're
missing 90% of the magic which is the
poet when the poet recites a poem is
completely different
yeah the performance the feeling so I
fell in love with it there and I started
writing but again just writing in a
notebook just keeping it to myself and I
eventually a friend we went to like a
coffee shop and they had like a spoken
word competition and then a friend said
you should enter you know try it out a
lot of pretty girls in the audience
let's see what we can do and then I
entered in I won and then that was kind
of my first foray into it and then
finding a spoken word collective in
Toronto they had that a website they had
like monthly events I started going to
those and then from there wanting seeing
things that were happening in my media
community and at that point speaking to
other adults and them kind of being like
these the kids these days they don't
listen to anybody the kids these days
they're all messed up you know whether
they're talking about drugs violence or
whatever and me I grew up in a
challenging neighborhood and as well as
I taught in a challenging neighborhood
and I said look it's not the kids
it's our messaging so I'm like let me
take a stab at it and so I was trying to
write a spoken word poem called voice
for the voiceless which was going to be
about various stories that were
happening in our community and I put
some music in the back it was jay-z's
Minority Report and in a moment there
was music in the back the words just
started to snatch on to that
and then that's the moment I realized oh
I can rap and then from that point
everything excited coming out as poetic
rap right and the name humble the poet
was kind of the reaction realizing the
hey like rap is such a high level of
literary art that doesn't get that
respect that it deserves and started
just releasing music blaring videos this
is like 2008 right like that's not that
long ago not that long ago the iy5 DIY
where influences like who were you
looking to Andre mm Lauryn Hill calming
CeeLo high five
yeah jay-z I think jay-z probably a
little bit less because I knew he didn't
write so I kind of felt like he was a
little too gifted for me to look up to
he was just like a natural talent
there's an artist out of he out of
Carson City California
rhaskos he really had that juxtaposition
of being from the hood but getting a
very high level of education
his mother taking him to museums
teaching him his own personal history so
the way he delivered his message was
very educated but not coming across that
he's smarter than anybody who became
obsessed with his work than the whole
ruckus movement most def to live quali
dead prez all of that is really
connected with me and it's probably
seeing hundreds mm and how cast ATLiens
they had that one track elevators 13th
floor and that track and one of the
music videos he's wearing a turban and
that just like does your mind blew my
mind is like a 14 year old kid seeing
this feeling whoa like I ain't never
seen a cool kid with determined before
it at that point the coolest kids that
knew what turbans were just the ones
that fought you know that's that was the
thing like there's a rough neighborhood
so the ones that fought back were were
the ones that had respect and they were
the ones that kept guys like me safe at
that point and following a level putting
words together and then that just
evolved in itself so then I was
releasing music just putting on lyric
videos not showing my face still scared
if the world knew what I was trying to
do and eventually people recognize my
voice somehow and then that voice would
have voiceless in Vancouver
there's a big drug trade over there and
he'll have a lot of gang violence in the
South Asian community and over a couple
of years ban about like 2 300 young men
were murdered at this violence so what I
ended up doing was I told that story in
song and then I listed every single one
at the end of the lyrics video and then
people just reached out like that's my
brother nobody has ever spoken to spoken
about him in a positive light before he
only just considered a criminal or that
was my cousin or I knew that guy I rise
to date that guy and not realizing that
I would have ever had some kind of
impact and not even showing my face at
this time and so slowly that just kept
evolving and I think in 2009 I was like
hey I could take this I should take this
a little bit more serious I liked and by
more serious I mean buying humble the
poet calm yeah and at some point some
people take some interest in in
cultivating this right like you have
this opportunity to record an album like
I've heard you kind of talk about it but
you dance around the edges of it so I'm
not sure I really understand kind of
what happened so I thought people took
interest in cultivating it what it was
as I had connected with a producer a
local producer but he was definitely the
most passionate artist I'd ever met at
this point and he really put a battery
in my back where he was like this wasn't
like we can make it it was like you need
to be heard like you should not be doing
anything else why are you working your
job like the world needs to hear this we
can make this happen and me at this time
not being you know I had I was working
in a school job but at the same time you
know I had made some investments in 2008
happened we all got our ass kicked so I
was like hey I got debt man I'm I gotta
work and like pay that off but you know
it wasn't anything that was stressing me
out because I had a salary and he's like
look man we'll figure it all out I can
help figure it all out I worked in Japan
I work with all these artists you know
there's a lot of markets a lot of ways
to make money in this game that you
don't know about you don't have to get
discovered by Puff Daddy and then we
really developed an intense friendship
and a brotherhood and he came from a
very challenging family situation and I
on the opposite had a very warm safe
kind family situation where I didn't
even realize other people didn't have it
as good as I did and then I welcomed I
welcomed her into my home and I and I
listen where you're living as toxic just
come stay with me and really just
embraced him and and I didn't have any
brothers so I realized now it was just
really chasing this feeling of having a
brother for the first time and then he
said he had secured us a record deal
which was gonna involve actually writing
for other artists so he sent me videos
of these other artists young kids
feeling old see this kid right here his
dad's rich he wants to help his kid
become a popular rapper the kid sucks we
can write for him we'll get paid in the
backend it wasn't great and it was
offering more money than I would have
made in two years as a teacher and I was
like this is a no-brainer like obviously
I love this lifestyle of just getting
inspired and writing stuff and now
you're saying give me a lot of money to
do so so there wasn't even due diligence
done on my part I really felt like he
was somebody that wanted to cultivate my
talent I realized that instead he he
didn't have something set up and he was
kind of I don't want to say in a furious
but I think he was trying to set things
up where he felt like he was gonna find
the money somehow yeah he's just like -
there's a fine line between hucksterism
and effective producing because part of
being a producer is kind of being ahead
of the game yeah but you know it's like
sort of sort of holding yourself out
like Moore's going on that actually is
and that's how deals are put together
but you extend yourself a little bit too
much and it's big time trouble that's
exactly what happened on my part I went
all-in at this point I have to develop
faith and trust
they've been trusting him but as well as
I fell in love with the lifestyle I
spent a summer in the bay living with
another independent rapper and just
living his lifestyle
and falling in love with it and he was I
mean he would he was a one-bedroom out
of a house that he was renting sleeping
on a couch and but every single day he
got up and like all right where's the
money working at before him and
sometimes it was performing on street
corners sometimes it was taking $20 gigs
at a local club but kind of just really
falling in love with just like the
energy the vibe every day being
different meeting new people and just
kind of really hey I want this for
myself too and now somebody is offering
me an opportunity to do this with some
upfront money and it at the same time my
actual career is humble the poet was
still working out well people were
discovering me
getting gigs and flowing out to
different cities to do shows none of
which were sustainable enough to pay my
mortgage and none of them were
sustainable enough to not have a second
job but things were still happening and
I got mixed up with that at the same
time thinking any moment when I got home
from this trip that that new check that
I'm waiting will be their cheques always
like 10 days away or the checks always
10 days away yeah and I mean I've since
learned especially working with you know
legitimate publishers check the check
can come in 24 hours you know like
there's this overnight nail the check
hasn't come it's not coming and you know
learning this you know learning it the
hard way and I was in and I believed a
lot of his lies because I wanted to I
take ownership for that yeah I wanted to
he wasn't a master manipulator I wanted
what he was selling and I wanted so hard
to believe it and so many people started
to show me the real situation and I
pushed them away I looked at them as
unsupportive and I'm like any moment
this is gonna all start to make sense
and then all year went by by time I
realized like this is not going to make
sense and he had since disappeared and
now I caught myself and ridiculous debt
with a mortgage living by myself not
knowing what I was going to do
feeling super sorry for myself blaming
everybody including the people who were
trying to help me and just think you
know everybody's fault really trying to
elicit people's empathy for me I wanted
people to feel sorry for me I wanted
people to feel my pain I wanted I wanted
it to feel as if nobody had ever
experienced what I had just experienced
before and you know having my heart
broken by women in the past being like
oh I only thought women can break Meyer
and now you know a homeboy broke my
heart all poor me you know like just
really sinking deep into it and just
turning to substances and turning to
inactivity and just really taking that
downward spiral
well this dismantling is your divine
moment yes you know and and a big part
of your work is is helping people
understand the holistic nature of the
human animal and this idea that nobody
is all bad and nobody is all good and
you know together were you know flawed
and beautiful and in pain and you know
the whole spectrum what it means to you
know
live a life right and when you look at
this producer it's very easy to put
yourself in the victim mentality and to
blame him and you know sort of paint
this you know picture of a not-so-good
person but ultimately this guy gave you
a gift which is he jettisoned you out of
a life that you might have lived for the
rest of you know your days and set you
on this journey that has been difficult
that forced you to meet your maker
but that crucible I think is what you
know formed the person that's sitting
across from me today Oh 1,000% and I am
I am grateful to him from afar I hold no
ill will towards him from afar so this
all meaning that there's no bad blood
but yeah we're not there's a difference
between you know resentment and like
discernment or boundaries yes exactly
and that's been my story with a lot of
people in my life which is like look
there's there's nothing there but at
this point like good luck to you and and
that's kind of probably my approach to
this as well most recently you know and
the other thing too in that situation
like the friends that I admit from his
his his ethos from that situation when
this all went down he lost them so I I
ended up inheriting all his friends
right and then when one of those friends
recently passed away two years ago I
think he tried to reach out to reconnect
because I think you know he had also
done that friend dirty he had borrowed
money from a lot of people and thought
he could just take take from here and
give to here and just continue that's
going on and it was he was operating out
of fear more so than some sort of you
know well-thought-out plan and he's just
trying to make it all happen and keep
afloat in thinking short term so there's
no ill will there and I definitely when
I was at my lowest and I finally hit
what was rock bottom at that time I
promised myself I said you have to
figure out a way to be grateful that
this happened to you for you to look
back because at that point this even
thinking about it impacted me physically
and it hurt me and I lived in a
condominium had to so it that's all all
my possessions and I had to move back
with my mom and my dad I couldn't drive
by that condo I couldn't go and that was
on a popular road
go downtown Toronto if I saw it it would
it would it would give me an involuntary
reaction just triggering a sense of
failure triggering a sense of failure
triggering a sense of what I gave up
because I was short-sighted and and and
I was you know saying things to myself
like you're so stupid you're so dumb
you're so naive you know that's self
bullying the self-talk you know so what
triggered you out of that I mean a lot
of people would just continue to take
that whole ad infinitum but for you to
have the you know the faculty the
facility to realize you were gonna have
to find gratitude somehow in order to
move forward I think it was a
combination of many things I mean the
simple romantic story was you know being
in bed and hearing some Jayco lyrics and
just like popping out and Jayco has some
lyrics about you know what you will you
let this turn will you allow this to let
you turn bitter and cold or will you
flip that [ __ ] dollar and turn it to
a dream that I remember was a moment
where I actually got out of bed but I do
think the two weeks of me isolating
myself and just laying in bed doing
nothing hoping on you know hoping to be
saved hoping that check would still come
yeah I feel like that might have
actually been some self compassion that
I needed to heal cuz that was hurt and I
needed to take some time so I think it
was a combination of that was a
combination of knowing that I did not
want to be what he was he found himself
in a difficult situation and ran and I
was I was not just in debt to the bank
so in debt to friends very good friends
people I cared about I didn't want to be
that guy who had to run from them so I
didn't want to I didn't want to be what
he was so I got to this point where like
I have to I have to have to bite the
bullet I have to call these people and
say look I owe you 10 grand
I don't have 10 grand I don't know how
I'm gonna make 10 grand but I will I'm
gonna figure it out and I'm not gonna
avoid you and at the same time you're
not gonna see me spending any money on
anybody else so I think did once I got
out of bed it was just you okay this is
all what's in your control and when I
realized I had to take responsibility to
find power and stop blaming the world
stop blaming other people stop feeling
sorry for myself because none of that
was giving me any power or helping me
recognize what was in my control yeah
there's an evolution there I mean in
order to jumpstart you out of your
teaching career you needed a guy who
believed in you yeah right
and that guy came in a very flawed
package very but he served that purpose
yes but in the process of working with
that individual you divested your
personal response you invested your
personal responsibility in him and just
that this guy's gonna do it for me back
then when that exploded you then had to
take responsibility of that for yourself
yeah and I would imagine there's some
epiphany that comes with that also which
is he didn't take away your talent or
your ability to write all of those
things remained intact and the same and
the truth is you had some momentum right
so you had to get a new prism and start
perceiving your world through your own
you know your own abilities rather than
relying on somebody else to kind of do
it for you exactly I always had the
wings he pushed me off the cliff yeah
and I've made much more concise way well
you know eyes down power yeah I know I
dabble in poetry once in a while but and
it was on and I probably would have
never done it and I have other friends
that you know have extraordinary talents
and ambitions and ideas that won't pull
that trigger because every single year
they hold off on it that salary that
they're working on their day job is
getting more and more comfortable and
they're creating a lifestyle that's more
dependent on it he took me out of that
situation right and I'm consulting on
before like I'm still here man it's all
gone and I and I got to that point where
they are you an $80,000 debt you have
zero ways of earning any money there's
nothing happening right now did you
think about going back and becoming a
teacher 1,000% 1,000% so initially again
my and at this point I'm still thinking
like I'm going to die like I'm going to
starve to death or I'm going to just go
nuts and jump off to Belk what's mom and
dad doing yeah what's mom and dad in at
the same time because it's like oh
they're gonna judge me they're gonna
they're gonna you know they're gonna
think I'm a failure people are gonna
think I'm a failure
and then that voice in my head like look
your worst-case scenario is
embarrassment your worst case scenario
is in debt this isn't a problem and I
went back home and they did like it
wasn't open arms it was we told you so
why did you do this
where's all your money how did you spend
all your money
we don't like they were like poking at
me like explained this like what did you
do and me having to be like eat this eat
these consequences
you you you put yourself in this
situation you don't get to run from this
you have to eat it and it was a very
uncomfortable couple years and me
figuring things out but and there was
nothing magical happening and then win
the lottery or anything I slowly started
looking around talking to different
artists and be like well how do you guys
are money what's what's going on and it
was like hey I applied for a grant I got
five grand to do a project
hey I sell t-shirts at my shows hey I
used crowd I used crowdfunding to book
shows I use hey I saw products and I've
read an article from James Altucher
about self-publishing and he was like
hey this is how you self-published and
doing this and I was like hey and at the
same time music I could I was like I'm
gonna keep making music and maybe I'll
start getting gigs and then music was
moving slow because it's such a
collaborative process working with other
people and I was full-time and they
couldn't keep up with my pace now
because they all had jobs and lives and
wives and stuff to do so then I had to
figure out what could I do by myself
that didn't require collaboration and
what that was writing so I was free
writing and finding images that inspired
me and writing stuff on Facebook and and
writing stuff in different places and
all of that ended up being my personal
therapy to kind of we kid through these
situations because what I was doing was
I wasn't telling my story but I was
telling what I was learning from these
stories I was like questioning coz
realizing that hey I was idealistic I
believed that anyone who saw my talents
wanted to help me you know that's you
know that was my my crash course and for
the entertainment industry realizing
like that's not how it works most people
that see your talents want figure out
how they can profit off of it and that's
but that's my responsibility to manage
my expectations accordingly
understanding that hey if I'm kind to
somebody that doesn't necessarily mean
the contract is they'll be kind back to
me and understanding the nature of
people and the nature of how things work
and learning that you can't simply pull
on people's heartstrings and get them to
do what you want you know people are in
it for themselves as well and understand
this and don't get all sad about it and
say the world sucks and there was a lot
of it
I was a student in school then I was a
teacher in school I was in this
insulated safe environment school is the
safest environment hide more alluring
iftar yet if there's you're taught as a
child like if someone does something bad
just go snitch on them to the teacher
and the teacher will handle it you know
that's the lesson I was teaching the
kids like run to the authorities they
will save you but in the real world
that's not how it is that now I have to
leave that Zoo and go into the jungle
and there's a lot more freedom but it's
way harder and it's a lot more work and
a lot more danger and you know a lot
less security that well perhaps the most
devastating is realizing all these
adults that you think had it all figured
out and know how to handle [ __ ] don't
really know what they're doing at all at
all yeah when I passed that age where my
mom had me that I'm like holy crap I
don't know what I'm doing and maybe they
don't know what they're doing so maybe
you know their words are no longer the
gospel and I should also kind of be
forgiving that they're not these
flawless human beings and which brings
it all back to the subject of unlearning
yeah it all goes back in it and that's
what I realized so in in that's the
title of the book is what I learned
because it wasn't that I had to figure
out something very specific there was a
there was a key or a secret to success
it was hey I'm carrying a lot of baggage
and ideas that are no longer relevant to
this new life that I had and I have to
ask the important and uncomfortable
questions to let them go and I have to
say to myself you know what what hand
did I have in this mess and the bigger
hand that I had him dismissed a bigger
hand I had to clean it up and that was a
really big one I don't think up into
that point I ever had to take any
responsibility for anything on this
level you know why why can't I Drive by
these buildings why is this shaking my
heart as if you know I just saw somebody
step on a puppy like why is this really
hurting me
and it was regret it was a reminder of
my failures and it's like well when when
is this gonna go away and it was a
combination of well it's gonna heal with
time but also it was gonna it's gonna
heal when you find a lesson not as this
when you find the value from this and
like alright I learned I learned my
lesson and then as time went on and I
slowly earned some more and I'm talking
about over four to five years I got I
got my you know
all happened at the end of 2011 I got my
bank account to zero at the end of 2014
and it was ok you've you've hit that
point and now you've learned a whole
bunch of skills on that way and this was
me simply being late alright Calgary I
want to come to play at your city but we
got to sell 50 tickets before I even
start organizing this can we sell 50
tickets and in the people rallying in
those 50 tickets sold so now I got some
seed money to throw the show to throw
the showing in Calgary and I'm realizing
hey I could sell my book alongside that
hey I can sell some t-shirts alongside
that okay learning the business of it as
well
and even that came at the sacrifice of
the art I went a whole year without
creating because I was on my laptop
being administrative and making flyers
yeah it's only shows but it added up and
it gave me a lot of tools and tricks and
at the same time continually putting
other work out and and and the book
never going away people anybody who
found the book and opened the book
connected with it so it went from an
independent release to two years later
getting picked up in Canada by Canada's
biggest books trying to go so it
initially came out self-published 2011
what you thousand 14 2014 okay yeah and
it's only now coming out in the United
States under HarperCollins so this book
has had like an unbelievable life that I
want to kind of you know deconstruct
here in a minute but but I don't want
this point to be missed which is it all
began with you taking responsibility
over the one thing that you had domain
over that didn't cost any money which is
this discipline of writing every single
day yeah right I think it was a Lilly
Singh who was the first person it was
like you don't need money you just said
you have this thing that you do like
just start doing it and and show up for
it every single day yes she was like
listen I I create everything I created
do by myself
and she's like figure out a way that you
can create by yourself right and I was
like I don't know how to make music
myself she's like then don't make music
do something else and she's like what
else can you do by yourself I'm like
well I can write just like then just do
it and then obviously I said everything
but I don't I don't know how to write
what she looked you'd like to stop
making the excuses and just get like
yeah you're already making excuses and
you haven't even
yeah and that's the thing with all of us
we're either making progress over making
excuses right and not to like underscore
the point or anything but like Lilly
Singh is now getting an evening talk
show on network television yes right and
I mean you can still put your money on
her because she's just getting started
against that yes she's still just
getting started and again and it's and
and and it's it's it's so clear-cut with
her as well it's it's she's going to
continue to rise because there is just
this work ethic that I have never seen
in any of the human being and you know
I'm sure we can you know deconstruct her
drive and in her history and how it came
to be but I got her her friends from
high school that said when she worked at
the fast-food joint
she was this much of a nerd as well and
like making sure she was cooking the
burgers perfectly making sure all the
straws were lined up all the forks were
lined up she's always been about vividly
doing anything is how you do everything
how you do anything is how you do
everything and it was such a gift that
we cross paths because at that point she
had not been doing anything she was she
was just starting YouTube and I was one
of three South Asian guys who knew how
to use YouTube because I was releasing a
music video like once every three months
so she had reached out to me for that
but then she took the comedy route and
and and again applied her talents with
her work ethic and took it to a whole
new level and she yeah she saved my life
in so many ways by by giving me that
kick in the ass to to start writing
every day but also continually not
allowing me to stray to the to the path
of least resistance knowing that hey
this is who you are you you're not
you're not you're here for the slow-cook
work you're not here for the quick
fast-food content you're not here to
simply win you're here to have a bigger
impact and she started creating an
environment for me to do so which like
all right come out here to LA and now I
have a place here's a room for you
here's a space with you I'm not you know
and being like make what you make and if
it takes six months to make it take six
months maybe but make sure you're
working and and don't fall into these
traps that you see all my you know my
colleagues doing which is just chasing
the new trend
working up the next thing that's popular
because that's not going to be
sustainable and that's not why you're
here
and that put me in a situation where it
allowed me to plant a lot of seeds and
years later now everything starting to
sprout yeah so whereas that original
producer was the guy who promised you a
fish she's saying let me help you learn
how to fish right she's giving you like
these lessons that allow you to you know
kind of create this foundation yeah
completely and as well as something look
this is how I fish take what you can
from it but figure out a way to figure
out your own way of fishing figure out
your own way of fishing that works for
you because if you start copying me
you're gonna you're gonna lose yourself
and you know and being able for us to
have you know open naked communications
and then we work on music together and
then I released a few songs with her and
then those songs did very well she's got
a great platform and you know she took
me on her world tour and I got to travel
the world and perform on stage with her
in and they did a documentary in the
documentary people hired me to be one of
the filmmakers for the world tour
because I had the ability to turn on the
camera during some of the more
uncomfortable situations that they
wouldn't have been welcomed into so just
a lot of opportunities were created from
that and it really taught me a lot about
how much power we had good again I think
being very successful in school without
having to put in a lot of effort almost
robbed me of the importance of work
ethic I didn't realize how hard I could
work let alone the importance of it and
then getting getting into her
environment into her world and seeing
how she did it was like this is all work
none of this involves talent this is all
work and now all of a sudden you you've
written so many scripts and you've
written so many post or captions or
pages that you know that's your 10,000
hours are coming because you're doing
the work and all of a sudden your stuff
sounds good but it didn't it you weren't
some naturally gifted individual it was
the baby steps were adding up you know
and you can't see it while it's
happening but looking back and feeling
all I've been doing this for six seven
years I'm getting really good at it
people just look at the results
somebody like that it looks easy it
looks very easy but it's not I don't I
don't even encourage I don't even tell
kids that they can grow up to be like
her because I'm just a I still don't I
mean we just we just had a game of
Thrones premiere party and in even the
process of decorating the house and
putting the whole thing together was
harder work than I enjoyed doing and I'm
just like I'm like why do you like I
know why do you enjoy doing this thing I
ever said to her I was like why do you
enjoy doing it and then I sent a picture
to one of my friends of like the
decorations and we had like heads on
stakes we had banners flags we painted
an entire tree just all these characters
and things from the thing in my friends
like is what you're rich people do and I
was like no rich people hire other
people to do this we spent the whole day
doing this this is obsessed crazy people
who loved in this and and that's
throwing parties is considered her my
art that I do for myself that doesn't
have an audience like it's not gonna go
on so she uh that I threw this party
this is from my personal satisfaction so
I think she's like bake cakes in a
previous life but the work ethic behind
it it's just so intense and I'm just
like this is bananas so I realized that
just being in a presence and even having
a fraction of her work ethic puts me
ahead of most people in the game because
people don't realize how much work it is
and I know Will Smith just posted
something recently where he's just like
everybody says they want to be an actor
they want to be this but they're not
willing to do the work that it takes and
it's an unhealthy amount especially if
you want to be a good person and do it
well I think social media has put a lens
on on that in a new and interesting way
if guys like Kevin Hart and and the rock
who you know and Will Smith who share
like look this is what it looks like
behind the scenes just see like this is
just incredible work ethic that goes
into what they're doing yeah relentless
you know or Mark Wahlberg getting up at
like 2:30 in the morning to like go to
the gym like this isn't just just it
doesn't get like rolled out in front of
them and it's not for display purposes
we you know the rock is a mentor to
Lilly and we were hanging out his
daughter came to hang out with us Simone
she's awesome and I asked I'm like is he
really waking up that early
yeah I'm like even like different parts
of the world she's like yeah I don't
even know how he does it he lies in he
goes straight to the gym yeah he fly the
other time it is I mean I could do that
if I'm in Toronto for like three three
months in a row or I can do that out
here I gotta buy the gym memberships but
it's like the second I get a little
jetlag like I'll make the excuses not to
go to the gym and it's just like these
people are doing it and they're
constantly making themselves
uncomfortable they're constantly leaning
into the discomfort in the new and
that's where all the growth exists and
it's in the beginning as what I
experienced it was involuntary life life
life just smashed me in the face and it
was either stay down and get up and you
know after some time I got up and I
learned a lot from it but now I'm in a
position where I have to lean into these
uncomfortable situations if I want to
continue to grow because life doesn't
happen on autopilot
there's no happily ever after is that
part of why you decided to write a book
rather than do an album or try to find a
way to pursue music first the music
never stopped and and I'm very fortunate
to have still a very very good music
career I still have you know I released
an album and in 2017 and past a million
spins and streams and a couple million
views on YouTube from for my self
directed videos I think what I realized
was when I was in that phase where I had
to earn earning earning money was
essential for my survival
it was spilling into the art and I
didn't like that so I kind of made
myself like I made myself a promise that
hey we have to figure out a way to to
earn and not let it impact the art and I
was really liking mos def mos def had
crashed the MTV Video Awards either he
rented a flatbed truck and performed
outside the radio city yeah and I just
thought to myself like he can do this
cuz he was just in the Italian Job and
like he's getting those movie checks so
he can afford his bail money and he can
afford to just make the music he likes
and I always thought that was super cool
so for me the again I wrote the book as
an independent thing and I'm like this
is better than selling a $20 t-shirt
people will find more value and then
just slowly
and went from you know a lot of young
young gentlemen coming to my hip-hop
shows putting their hands up you know
and having fun too a lot of girls
showing up a book in hand thinking that
they were attending a reading because I
would just be like humble the poet live
in Vancouver and they were just like hey
you're not gonna read from the book and
I'm saying oh I never thought people
were interested in that and then you
know that in combination with my
affiliation with Lily gave me an even
bigger female audience and you know as
an educator understanding that most
books are geared towards the learning
styles that females have and more
females read books and MIT than males
just based on how we kind of present
books to them so that really kind of
shifted things and again it just didn't
go away like I finished the book and
then the moment I got out of debt and
found different streams of revenue I
went straight back into music and then
when I got my first offers for book
deals in 2017 in Canada I said no to all
of them and I said no I'm gonna I'm
gonna just focus on music and have fun
because at that point I just done an
apple commercial an iPhone right in
Michelin I got tried to find that online
they feel like I just read it from the
internet yeah I have it I couldn't find
it if they had it living on YouTube and
I check a day it's gone yeah so it was
for Canada's 150th birthday right so I
think they probably just played it for
that for that month but um I'll send it
to you I have it yeah
but that that put me in a good situation
as well so then I was like okay well the
this publishing deal doesn't sound
because when they offered me a
publishing deal it's like hey we wanted
for the next book and I was like well
this book that I have unlearn has been
doing very well independently you guys
are a bigger trampoline can we bounce it
off that I really think it's gonna work
and at that point all the traditional
publishers the big three said oh we
don't traditionally do that yeah and I
pretty rare that they do that yeah they
don't and I think at this point I was
already kind of warned hey anytime
somebody says we don't traditionally do
anything run the other way like at this
point like that doesn't the kind of
people you want to work with so I left
and then indigo which is the I guess we
can kind of say the the Canadian
equivalent to Barnes and Noble they but
they found a they found there they found
their space dude they're doing well in
Canada they sell more than just
books and but they're the biggest
bookstore in the entire country they're
like we're starting a publishing wing we
love to take that first book that you
wrote and and and republish it and at
that point they literally just wanted me
to email them the files so I said oh
yeah it's the PDF that was it you've
been selling a lot of books up to that
point I know you had like a television
appearance that kind of that's where it
clicked in yeah Canada Reads yeah I was
on I was on the show where we debated
books and then I debated a book called
15 dogs and that was just a fun they had
four other public figures and we all
picked books that we were near near and
dear to us and we we had to debate which
book we felt the whole country should
read and and I had picked the book
called 15 dogs which is about 15 dogs
that were granted human intelligence by
these two Greek gods who were in a bar
having a bet about whether human
intelligence makes us miserable so they
gave these 15 dogs in Toronto human
intelligence and we just followed their
stories until they died to see if any of
them can die happy so for me the
showrunners had sent me boxes of books
to pick from and all the books were
about the immigrant experience the South
Asian experience like very superficial
and I was like well the things I
actually love ours I love dogs which you
probably noticed I love dogs I love my
city of Toronto and I love this idea of
its being intelligent more of a gift or
a curse and this book and it was short
and then so I picked this book and I
probably the only person who didn't have
a personal stake in his book where his
book wasn't telling his story and I
ended up winning the debate very easily
over the over the week and yeah that put
me on the map it was quite it was quite
a few things that's weak and you have a
book yeah and yeah that also helped me
get that Apple commercial that's also
will help me get that and I had never
heard of the show before but it was a
very part for the show and he also
played it on the radio so it was it
really got me very popular with it with
an older demographic which is very
refreshing you meet him on the street
and they're not asking for selfies they
just want to have like real
conversations with you so that was a
super dope change of pace and yeah
publishers hit me up they all they all
did not want to publish the book I moved
on to music and then while
making my music and to go reached out
sent them to the PDF and forgot about it
against kept working on the music and
then when they dropped the book it hit
the bestsellers list and before that
independently I probably sold about five
or six thousand copies over a couple
years
but I mean independent I was probably
making eight nine bucks yeah a book
American and in Canada a few more so it
was it was enough I think I was like
averaging like two three books a day it
was enough to help me keep afloat with
my simple lifestyle and then once
started doing very well with them I
started speaking to some folks out here
and then they connected me with Mark who
you just met and then he got me from out
in the u.s. no it's crazy it's this is
five years later and yeah it's just
being introduced to an American audience
like this is a book that's how this long
crazy life and you know in publishing
there's so many books that come out and
books come out and they do really well
but then they're gone the physical
disappear like they'll hit the New York
Times bestseller list but then it was
yesterday's news and it's pretty rare
that you find a book that which stands
the test of time continues to sell over
the long run I mean that's the thing
that I'm most proud about with my book
like it's still that's because of the
podcast like there's new people being
introduced to it yeah the fact that you
have this book it's coming out now and
you just get these continuous bites at
the Apple of introducing more and more
people and it's interesting as you as
you said it's not common in publishing
so the book dropped uh about a week and
a half ago or on a third print Wow and I
mean I'd love to say that they printed a
whole bunch and that's why we're on the
third print but I think it has to do
with their Hanna's managed expectations
yeah and all of a sudden got to emailing
Oh Amazon just indicated to us that
they're running out of stocks or we're
gonna be doing more prints so I'm happy
that I'm exceeding their expectations
and I'm still learning that space as
well again coming from digital things
move a lot quicker so I was like oh you
know we hit we peaked at 37 on Amazon of
all books and I hit number one on poetry
even though it's not a poetry book 37 of
all books yeah right now that's
happening at
Amazon the first week yeah I think now
we probably flipped a little bit but
that's you know that's amazing yeah and
people a lot you know sent it out to a
lot of influencers a lot of them posted
about it but then I started reaching
outside my grasp and then people that I
had never met before I started posting
about the book people were big following
sharing it and again and I always
believed it and it's to the point for me
now is just I don't even take personal
ownership of this book it's it's what
saved me it's it's it's it was the
process of getting me out of the hole I
was in and I tell people like this book
saved my life in so many ways and it
will help other people and you know I
had to let go of my my Canadian
sensibilities and my quote/unquote
humbleness to be like no no this book
this one has legs and you just have to
open it you can open it to any page you
will connect with it that's and that's
the thing that I've been really pushing
on people it's working and I'm really
excited now that it's out on the biggest
stage you can be out on and it's being
bounced off the biggest trampoline you
can because I feel like it's going to be
around for a long time well like any
piece of art once it's released to the
world it is it becomes the public domain
yes right it's it's not yours to define
yes absolutely for the audience to
decide what it is yet and to make it
their own completely and I think and I
feel like my only job right now is to do
the work to get people to just want to
check it out yeah see if they well
explain explain this concept of
unlearning a little bit more if the idea
that many of us have a lot of tools and
personality traits that were probably
beneficial to us at different times in
our lives you know I grew up in a
challenging neighborhood the way I had
to act the way I had to maneuver back
then doesn't apply where I am now in my
life or even apply when I was a teacher
you know I grew up in high school where
making eye contact meant you wanted to
fight and but working at the teacher you
were supposed to make eye contact and
say good morning to everybody so
learning certain things and realizing
the hey you have to let go of a lot of
these things and understanding that
these things many of them you know we're
socialized into us and we had to not
simply look at this debate of nature
versus nurture and see how they both
work together so for me I learned was
the idea that we can let go
to really gain more from our lives as
opposed to acquiring some new mystical
skill that people have yet to tell us
and it's a secret that we're so
hardwired for that though I just want to
accumulate and accumulate Jim you live
in an additive frame of mind but I feel
like that's on this side of the planet
I'm not sure how I feel like that's it
is the consumeristic religious
experience to kind of experience it that
way and I feel like in other parts of
the world people aren't acquiring as
much and they're kind of just going
through the motions or existing and not
doing the 40 50 60 hour a week work Ryan
the way we do it
and I think just being mindful of that
having to travel and believe oh crap
people live differently people have
different priorities being in India once
and seeing these two kids knocking I
wasn't I was in a car and these two kids
were knocking on the window saying you
know would you poo cloggy I'm hungry I'm
hungry but at the same time they're both
laughing uncontrollably because they've
just been trained to beg but they were
having a good day and they were just
laughing at something that they were
goofing around with me being like these
kids are happier than right now the most
most other people I know and starting to
disconnect the relationship between our
circumstances and our happiness and you
know it difficult for someone to be like
hey money won't make you happy and say
that to somebody doesn't have money
because somebody who doesn't have money
is gonna be like well give me all the
money then if it's not making you happy
but then it slowly growing into the
situation we were like well I was
struggling and I promised myself to feel
great when I'm no longer struggling and
in realizing like hey I just filled I
just dealt with one challenge and new
challenges opened up because of that
whether it was having a relationship
with the taxman or whether that came
with you know having family members of
it have expectations of you know you
know certain things people finding out
I'm gonna be on certain podcasts and
being like oh I better be there when
you're on that podcast and I was like
doesn't that's not how it works I can't
just have my family's been here when I'm
with Rich roll there was somebody else
then they could come yeah well I
appreciate that for here and then then
you know maybe just kind of been like oh
I didn't know that these are new
challenges and kind of really owning
this idea that look you solve one
problem life is a series of obstacles
and challenges there isn't
you're not going to overcome the last
one and just
I doubt your days like we used to see on
television yeah well this this idea that
permeates your work also is this idea of
cycles and life being cyclical instead
of this you know where we set ourselves
up to you know adhere to some perfect
upward trajectory of happiness and
prosperity this you know obviously
unattainable and just makes us feel
ashamed and terrible about ourselves
when in truth life and all its natural
systems work in these cycles and the
more we can embrace the natural aspect
of that then a happier and the more
content we can be with those obstacles
that we face when they arrived
completely and I think that's you know
you hit it on the head and I think
that's the idea where we have to be like
well why do I think it's that way why am
I thinking linear in a linear sense to
begin with why do I believe that just
over the horizon everything will be
better
why do I say I have to I'll have some
fun after I'm done my work because the
works not gonna end you know why do we
believe in these happily ever afters and
then starting to recognize the sources
of our influence and immediately okay
well if I want to let go of this idea
and and make room for a new idea or go
back to how I used to view life when I
was a child and which was full of
curiosity and confidence and and and
risk-taking what what was piled up on
top of me to get to this point and you
know really trying to take the rust off
think that you know take the sat at the
back I say you know this book is the
sand paper to take that rust off and
take some of these old ideas away and
also recognizing the hey I had to I had
to have some of these qualities because
they were important at one point in my
life but we are we are constantly
growing evolving beings and we can't
remain stagnant so unlearn for that it
the the idea behind it was to let go of
these but I took it from a perspective
of not to make it about myself but to
help people you know use my abilities to
put words together to help other people
figure out their own situation so you
know you learn you learn about me
through reading this book but not a lot
this is this book is not about me this
book is about us and
that we're all in the same boat the fact
that this book was only written because
people read my writing repeatedly said
you should write a book because they
connected with it so because we all have
regrets from my past we all have worries
for our future you know we all have
expectations that we don't know where
they came from and then we all get very
unhappy when those expectations aren't
met you know we all make decisions to
avoid failure we all make decisions to
avoid heartbreak you know we all can get
starts thinking in hyperboles and in
saying that this always happens this is
never gonna happen we all do this and I
think if we recognize that we're all in
the same boat and we can all find
something new to connect upon with each
other and start that process of letting
some of these things go especially if
they're just holding this back in life
we all hold grudges you know we all are
carrying around a lot of baggage that is
not serving us any purpose other than it
weighing us down so on learning was this
whole idea that you already have what
you need and there's just a lot of stuff
that needs to get unclogged and I'm not
here to promise you some sort of secret
other than forcing you to ask yourself
some uncomfortable questions and being
completely honest with yourself to go
through this process I don't want to I
don't want you to read this book and
think I'm a self-help guru because I'm
definitely not you kind of look like one
now you could be one of you wanna be one
hey you know I think you know what the
popular yeah with the popularization of
like you know osho and all these Netflix
documentaries and you know people
thinking I'm wise guy got a nice beard
yeah my beard is my source of my wisdom
but I think the big thing I just want
the world to understand is I am a flawed
human being that enjoys making mistakes
because I'm gonna take the time to learn
from those mistakes and the more of a
public figure I become most likely those
mistakes are gonna become more public
and I want y'all to just hear about them
be like yeah that's our boy like he got
himself into some dumb [ __ ] and we're
excited to see what he learned from that
as opposed to me trying to be all high
and mighty and again the goal here was I
taught eight-year-olds
I was aiming to speak to everybody's in
a child here
yeah and were they teaching you they
taught me so much they definitely did I
think that's the the process that that
was the big poll for me to get into
education was wanting to be a lifelong
learner it's sick means student you know
I don't like the idea of the years going
by and and being like where did the time
go
I want it to be like hey who I was in
2017 is so far from Who I am now because
the time didn't fly by it's all these
new experiences and challenges brought a
whole new side of me out and that's
exciting and then like going to Ted
learning certain ideas that had never
thought of before also this sick idea of
oneness and unity
you mentioned unity a minute ago kind of
informing your your perspective and and
your writings all of that and I'm
curious about how you then take that
perspective and how that informs how do
you think about your own cognitive
biases and what separates you from your
fellow man and how you kind of navigate
the you know toxic treacherous waters of
you know dialogue breakdown that we see
in social media or in any kind of like
political dialogue that's happening or
what respect to that you know the daily
news yeah I think for me you know my
heritage specifically being Punjabi and
specifically being of Sikh heritage is
six-six are very martial we have a
history of mobilizing forming armies
fighting oppressive regimes never being
passive and I mean that goes back from
our founding our founding gurus of sicky
all the way up to you know Punjabis
representing 2% of India but making
about 40 to 50 percent of all people who
died fighting the British for
independence we've always had that so I
think my I I grew up having a certain
relationship with conflict which was
it's it's it's okay it's normal and for
me now as an adult that's not really
manifesting itself in terms of violence
but it does manifest itself in terms of
just like having uncomfortable calm
having a little bit of friction being
okay being challenged being okay to
challenge other people not enjoying any
type of passive aggressiveness and I
think for me enjoying being challenged
so you know even in this conversation
when you state an idea that is you know
say I have I have a counter idea to what
you have to say like me getting excited
to hear that and knowing that Oh at this
age I'm about to learn something new
because so you know so few of us are
putting ourselves in these positions to
continually learn new things so I think
my my biases on that point I keep them
very I don't plant them into my identity
I am not my beliefs you know I am I am I
heard a very good quote that there is no
generation gap there are just people who
are open to new ideas and people who are
not open to new ideas and I've
definitely seen that I've definitely
seen very young people who were who have
been raised a certain way and they're
not open to an idea different than them
I myself have the fondest memories I
used to be homophobic I used to think it
was wrong to be gay like I like I was
allowed to have that opinion and I got
to have beautiful experiences meeting
people and seeing the human side of all
this and me like who was I to make these
judgments and being grateful that you
know I was open to changing and evolving
becoming a better person and I'm excited
to continually do that whether it's
realizing my priorities or my values
they might not be what they need to be
even today meeting with my agent and
having a discussion about okay well you
know what what leverage can we you know
for a next deal with set leverage heals
I don't think you should look at this in
terms of leverage look at this in terms
of collaboration you know mainly okay
this is I'm learning that there are
people that he sees this in a much more
mature manner than I'm seeing that right
now and this is a business meeting so
and I like that I like being proven
wrong that's luck you know I like
knowing that I'm not going to be stuck
as Who I am so I think for me there's
the excitement there and there isn't a
challenge when there is friction with
that and I also feel like I learned
something new this past week when
dealing with conflict and it was enter
conflict with a question not an answer
so give me an example of
you know if we weren't political you
know right now people are like Trump is
the devil and other people like know
he's the Savior everyone's coming in
with an answer and maybe just going in
and saying let's have a healthy dialogue
well what is it about this this
candidate that's making you so excited
and hearing and most like you you'll
probably hear a bunch of answers of
somebody sharing the same values that
you share which might be like hey I feel
like my job is more secure with this guy
in charge hey I feel safer with this guy
hey I feel like my voice matters and you
might start to hear things and then a
healthier discussion can can can arise
from that and I'm not saying everybody
will join your team but there might be a
healthier version of agree to disagree
out of that me personally looking the
way I look in the beginning it was I
felt it so frustrating that I could
never just blend in I could never be a
fly on the wall because people were
constantly either challenging me overtly
like why do you look like that what is
that on your head what you know I
remember being nine and being told a
woman saying I'm offended that you came
to my country looking like this not
knowing what the word offended meant and
then somebody else you know learning the
term at probably eight you know when in
Rome not knowing what that meant I was
like why do you look like that and I was
like well you know this is how my people
looked like well when in Rome and they
didn't even change the sentence and in
the beginning I hated it I just wished I
could just be invisible and not be
notice and not be seen by anybody now
I'm seeing the value of it you know and
I and I grew up in Toronto I grew up in
one of the most multicultural places on
the planet my brother-in-law I grew up
in a small farm town outside of Toronto
and you know his family on a corner
store and people stopped doing business
once they they took over that corner
store and he'd get chased by kids who
were trying to like beat him up with a
baseball bat after school and you can
see the resilience that that built in
him and the value so I think I see the
value in conflict I see the value in
that historically sick people being a
minority everywhere that they exist
we've never been able to we've never
even heard this term safe space
that's never been something there you
know it 200 years ago
you know the ruling King of the area was
paying people to bring our heads you
know you find a thick you cut off his
head I will pay you for it you know and
these guys had to decide hey should we
hide or should we just tie bigger
turbans and be like alright
come come try to get stand taller stand
taller yeah but always being the
minority among the minorities always
being the planet exactly and I think
that's where you know there isn't I
don't have a homeland where I fit in
even even as me as an individual you
know I'm exotic when I'm out here I'm
exotic over there
I can't blend in and India I can't blend
in and Punjab they see the tattoos they
see the way I walk they see the way I
dress they know I'm not from there right
but you just double down on it by by
putting on just like crazy sweats and
like you know just rocking the super
bright turban and the whole thing you're
like yeah I mean I am Here I am here I
mean there's definitely moments where
I'll and I'll be completely honest I
think when I was younger I used to see
these very eccentric dressed people and
I thought they were weirdos and there
have been moments when I'm walking down
the street and they're like I'll pass by
a mirror and stop like oh I didn't even
realize how weird yeah I looked and how
bright I looked and it might be LA
because in LA this doesn't even stand
out nothing stands out in LA everybody
there's some notable like weren't worse
right he's a guy who's always impeccably
dressed he's a huge artist he's such a
such a brilliant artist and I just
recently connected with him a few years
back and learned his story and it was
kind of the same thing he was like man I
just wanted to make cool stuff and find
cool people that make cool stuff but I
didn't think about my relationship to
the community I grew up in the
neighborhood where our people there
weren't any of our people so for me it
was now it's kind of like I'm always
chasing community and I'm chasing people
that I feel would understand me and it
ended up being these you know like these
pants are from a Toronto designer you
know she she gifted them to me that's
why I'm wearing them I designed this
shirt that you know did you know this
was given to me as a gift to so I'm
wearing I'm wearing the shoes were
gifted to me so I'm wearing stuff that
was given to me and
I think I definitely got so used to
standing out regardless and it wants to
became a public figure even
independently I started standing out
amongst my own people so that was no
longer a place I could just blend in
even in Toronto so if I'm in a high
Punjabi community you know in you know
the Brampton's and the mall tunes which
are west of the city you know they all
know who I am so I'm getting stares for
different reasons and then if I go an
hour outside of Toronto to like the
hockey towns they're all staring at me
for different reasons and you just get
used to being stared at and then just
kind of like okay this is my reality
it's no longer uncomfortable I built a
resilience because they'd mr. Burnett me
since I was eight yeah but this this
sort of acute kind of awareness of
different kinds of stares like is that
you're at the hockey is that like I want
to kill you stare or like oh I saw you
on YouTube stare in the beginning you
know what though in the beginning
I interpreted literally every stares I
want to kill you uh-huh and then I had a
I had a warrior default the warrior all
life the 90% of the experiences I had
were very violent on some level they
were they were there were people yelling
at me and this is even pre 911 I mean
just just kids you know teasing me
making fun of me you know taking the
stereotypes that they saw in the films
you see a guy you know you watch go
watch men in black'''s an Indian guy
driving the cab it's it was a lot of
stereotypes and and and I'm not the only
community who has stereotypes and
Hollywood films and then afternoon sorry
to interrupt you but like this is what I
spoke with a car shilada
yeah like you know and he was talking
about these just these very same things
and the iconography and pop culture is
just deplorable right you know there's
the the guy from The Simpsons what's his
name you know yeah like that's basically
it it's like the guy works at 7-eleven
and and he works at 7-eleven the accent
it doesn't exist
you know and in going even the idea of
being Indian Indian is in the language
Indian isn't a food Indian isn't a type
of music you know India is a collection
of cultures and foods and languages and
faiths you know India should be a
continent not a country you know and it
was created by you know the Empire and
so for me
dealing with all that experience but
then 9/11 happened and now when you
think of what a beard and turban
represents it then it was like get out
of my country terrorist then it was
people thinking putting you know trying
to punch you in your face would it help
them score some points and you know bull
bear Singh Sodhi was it with a man with
a beard and turban who owned a gas
station in Arizona and he was just
gardening outside his gas station and
somebody shot him in the head and that
man said I'm doing what George Bush is
too scared to do you know and Enki and
then also being in that situation we
were like I don't want to tell people
I'm not Muslim because that's just still
throwing another group under the bus and
trying to find wasted to deal with that
but getting used to that to the point
where you just I you're always on edge
like why is that person staring at me
and then having these these moments of
beauty you know there was one moment in
New York where I was at a at a hip-hop
concert in Brooklyn and from the corner
of my eye I could see this redheaded guy
who looked very drunk just staring at me
very intensely and my mice and I I went
my heightened I was like ah [ __ ]
something's gonna happen
and then he got closer and closer and
closer and then he was right beside me
and I was like aw crap like like trying
to find a beer bottle or some to protect
myself and he's like are you Punjabi and
I was like yeah and he goes I just spent
four months in Chandigarh which is the
capital of Punjab and he goes I just
landed and I'm flying back to the bay
and I'm so happy to see a Punjab because
I lived with Punjabis perform once and
it's you're making me so happy to see
you right now and all of a sudden means
it's like being like holy [ __ ] like why
you know why did I assume that this guy
was coming to me with with such
aggression and it was it was loved
there's been times - which is even like
women have looked at me and I was like
are they judging me or and then coming
up to me being like I love everything
about the way you look you look so
handsome and realizing that hey there
are people that that look a certain way
and have judged me a certain way but
there are other people with open hearts
and open minds that don't see that and
they see something completely different
and then you know getting out of my own
bubble it's starting to see that and
realizing that different cultures find
beards attractive and now that we have
new generations of kids that are growing
up seeing multiculturalism they've seen
Morris and the gap ads and you know
they've seen comedians like just rain in
different places they've see my stuff
you know that Lily Dez has helped you
know catapult me into a lot of homes and
into a lot of people Z so so now it's
kind of being open to it being like look
they may be approaching with love they
may be approaching with aggression trust
yourself to handle it accordingly
and it's not going to go away either way
and I was in Peru a couple years back
and that was the adults literally in the
same minute and one adult walked by and
goes hey Osama and then literally an
another child walks playing goes hey Bob
Marley you know and it's all yeah it's
all context but I think that's
illustrative of not just how polarized
this is right now but how lightened it
is I mean with you know politics as they
are at the moment and the way kind of
you know social awareness has grown also
kind of in tandem with regressive ideas
around culture you have a celebration of
multiculturalism like we've never seen
before and an acceptance and an embrace
of it and we also have this you know
fear-based relationship with it that is
at a you know a peak that I haven't seen
in my life so you know I would imagine
as you navigate this kind of being at
the vortex of it like you're you're
you're gonna get these extreme
encounters on one end or the other and I
think that's what is really happening is
the fringe that the opposite ends of the
spectrum there have there such an
amplified voice now even if they don't
represent what most people are thinking
and I think I've had those experiences
where you know I have been accused of
you know pushing a far-left agenda or
I've been I've also been accused of
pushing a far-right agenda I've also
been accused of working for the Indian
government to pollute my own my own
population I've also been accused by
working for terrorist organizations in
the Sikh community to dismantle the
Indian Gaur you got all the bases
covered I got them all covered and I
don't know everybody you know no one's
happy yeah cuz I'm because to be Punjabi
congratulations you're an artists
yes you're an artist and I'm okay with
the idea that my stuff can make people
feel uncomfortable even though I don't
really think I'm doing anything too
controversial but I understand that
people's beliefs people have mistaken
their beliefs for their identity and
that's chapter in the book you are not
your beliefs and I said I'm here to [ __ ]
with your beliefs what you believe is
what you believe is not who you are if
somebody criticizes your beliefs are not
criticizing who you are and I think
that's an important thing to understand
and we need to be open to the idea that
we can pull out these these flags of
beliefs and let them go if they're no
longer serving as a purpose and if that
you know again I'm a big a big proponent
of self responsibility in a political
standpoint that means listen you got to
not lean on the powers that be to take
care of you anyways and if you're
self-sufficient most of this stuff is
not going to impact you the way it is
and if you're not happy with the way
things are get off your computer go
outside and and mobilize and vote
somebody new in or you know organize
some sort of campaign to make things
happen and if you're not happy with the
homeless situation in your neighborhood
get involved don't call 9-1-1 like do
things to be involved take some personal
responsibility and sometimes that comes
off as an unpopular opinion but it's
important to say and because it does get
people feeling and that's the purpose of
an artists the purpose of an artist is
to introduce ideas that may not have
already existed on this planet and their
number-one enemy is always going to be
the fundamentalist and fundamentalism on
the simplest definition is those who
think the past is better the way we did
it before is better and what we're
seeing that now people are missing the
good old days and make America great
again well the core a core component of
fundamentalism in whatever you know body
it finds itself is that close
identification of identity with belief
right if you can't separate those two
things you are gonna be you're gonna be
unable to not only have be able to learn
anything new you're gonna be going
through life in a fixed mindset and I
think this is at the core at the very
center of this breakdown
and healthy public discourse yeah you
were talking earlier about you know how
you kind of bridge that gap on an
individual basis through your own
personal experiences with people but how
can we scale this up because when I look
at the health of conversation right now
yeah it's pretty poor and I think unless
we can address and heal this were we're
gonna capsize as a culture because we
can't communicate effectively because
we're so siloed and we're so our beliefs
are so identified with our identity and
any any sort of challenge to them is an
attack on who we feel we are as human
beings you're absolutely right and if
the economy of social media that
dictates hey rich likes this type of
content let's only put this type of
content in front of him which creates
these echo chambers you know now it's
you're not going to come across somebody
who says something you don't like to
hear because the social media platforms
their business model requires you to
stay on their platform as long as
possible
so they don't want to offend you you
know they want to get you engaged so
they might put some outrageous stuff in
front of you they may put some
conflicting stuff in front of you maybe
even polarizing stuff in front of you
but at the same time they're still
curating your feet and I'm not even sure
if the average social media user
understands that their feed is curated
for them specifically your Netflix is
curated for you specifically there's
there's hit shows and movies on Netflix
that you're never going to see because
it doesn't line up with your viewing
habits and the more we're looking at
these screens the more our respective
realities diverge from one another
completely but we're unaware of that we
think everyone's looking at the same
queue of Netflix movies yeah realize you
know the person sitting next to you is
having a completely different experience
completely different experience and I
think it goes back to that personal
responsibility of being mindful of this
so for me I again even online I try to
dip myself into places I wouldn't
normally go whether it's on conservative
websites and reading what they're trying
to say understanding how they're trying
to say it I was I was speaking with
somebody yesterday who wrote for The
Daily Show and he's like you know
the level of education required to just
try to decipher the truth out of the
news these days it's so high and nobody
wants to do the work let alone even read
the articles they just want to read the
headlines and for me it's it's
recognizing that on a grand global scale
to shift that wave it's only gonna be
able to happen by holding some of these
social media companies accountable I had
add some talks with some of the
higher-ups and social media companies
and they you know I think the one honest
thing that they keep communicating to me
is that we can't do anything overnight
I think the other part is kind of like
well can you change it even if you could
do it overnight would you because your
business model requires the economy of
attention your business model requires
us to pay as much attention as possible
will it ever be in a situation where
people like alright you spent enough
time on here today like we're gonna cut
you off and me personally have you know
I'm a big I'm a big reddit nerd I love
being on reddit which is also in an
ecosystem that we can curate for
ourselves but I've set a time around my
browser for 30 minutes so I have 30
minutes max on reddit in my favorite
hip-hop web sites and they're all junk
food it's all quick gratification it's
all you know I'm not immune to reading
up some some gossip I'm not immune to to
staring staring at pictures of cute
puppies and and just all these little
little drops of dopamine but it's
becoming aware of it and realizing that
hey this stuff is no different than fast
food it's quick cheap easy and
convenient but keep doing it for a long
time
addictive very very addictive I think we
need to really appreciate the extent to
which it creates an addictive response
and I had I had Jack Dorsey on the
podcast and we talked about this very
thing with respect to Twitter and he
seems I mean he he understands the
problem and he seems committed to
addressing it one of the ideas he had is
to reorganize the feeds such that it
becomes less dependent on likes and
retweets and also less dependent on
following individuals and more in
alignment with following issues or
subject headings that can then be
curated so that
contains a mix of perspectives to
broaden you know people's perspective
outside of their silo now whether that's
idealistic or doable time will tell
you'll see but at least these
conversations are happening and I think
the more that people can get in touch
with the fact that the information
you're information diet you know is
tailored specifically to you and to the
extent that you can create habits that
force you to step outside of that and
entertain different perspectives and ask
more questions and do more listening
when you're you know engaged in those
you know in real life conversations
you're at least you know living more in
the solution completely in and again
addiction is addiction and I know you
know some people will be like well I'm
not addicted or look at all these people
addicted to their phones and I don't but
I think people have to understand that
like addiction is you know we might have
made some poor choices to get to this
point but once you're hooked you're
hooked and we have to view it with some
sort of compassion it just can't simply
be like kick that habit it's the same
thing with alcohol it's the same thing
with other substances it's the same
thing with self-pity it's an addiction
manifests itself you know as a results
of some of our poor choices when we
might not have had the tools to make the
right choices to get here but now that
we're here we have to approach it I feel
like we have to approach it the way we
approach people with diabetes you know
we have to we have to look at this as
something that as a health issue now and
we have to approach it with treatment
like a health issue instead of just kind
of waving our finger at these people in
melee well you're hooked on to this
stuff now and you're part of the problem
ah yeah yeah shame on you and I mean I'm
very curious to see because he also was
at Ted and he did a Q&A there yeah he
got excoriated for that he it was it
like in real life it was um the format
was challenging so they all gave us a
hashtag to ask him questions and then
the questions range from like smart
questions to like why haven't you
deleted Trump's Twitter yet to do you
know you're the devil and at the same
time these are all scrolling in the back
and then I think the moderators are like
okay well we're not gonna read these at
the same time everyone
kind of reading yeah oh my god yeah so
he's sitting on the couch with two for
two folks and I don't know if this'll
ever make it to the public Ted for him
but he's sitting there with two
moderators and then they had the
beautiful screen in the back and then
they they were putting everybody's
tweets on the back and that's just
scrolling and I guess their plan was to
originally read some of these questions
but the questions weren't like cute and
fun right they weren't like what's your
morning routine they were just like why
haven't you deleted Trump's Twitter how
do you feel that you're part of the
problem and like stuff like that so none
of the challenging questions kind of
made it to him they did kind of poke at
him when he didn't have her question
clearly because he doesn't kind of dance
around a lot of it I do kind of feel
like a lot of these these these guys who
created these just like World Genting
ideas in platforms whether it be Twitter
whether it be Google or Facebook I feel
like they are probably looking a they
probably zoomed out a lot more than we
might realize and they're looking at
this from a completely different
perspective and I don't know if they can
articulate that perspective as well but
at the same time I mean like who is the
priority is it your shareholders is it
the people is it the mental health of
the situation is it the healthiness of
democracy well the honest answer is
there are competing interests right and
and that's what makes it difficult and
you know with respect yeah I can only
speak to Jack because he's the only one
I know yeah
but I have kind of a controversial you
know hot take on it which is that and
this is based purely on my personal
experience with them and listening to
him and other interviews my feeling is
that he is a very intelligent person who
helped create this thing that he could
have never foreseen
you know would would put this dent on
the universe in the way that it has and
he's now and an almost impossible to win
situation of trying to figure out how to
curtail it and you know curate it in a
way that does promote healthy global
conversation whether he can succeed in
doing that who knows but my sense of him
is that he really is
he's trying you know he's
well-intentioned and he does care
because he doesn't have to go to Ted and
put himself in these situations where
he's going to get criticized on that
level and I think he does think about
these issues deeply and he's committed
to finding a solution and I think that
in a how long ago culture would you talk
to him I was at his house like a month
ago or something like that
I spent like a whole afternoon with him
if we don't say how long for you
personally before if we don't see any
new feature ads or any new changes are
you gonna be like okay that was just
kind of I got laid I got played over a
third yeah I don't know yeah yeah it's a
good question I don't know the answer to
that you know was I was i manipulated or
did I see this human being as I want to
see her but I do feel like this is a guy
who like has gone to great lengths to
keep his life very controlled and sparse
and minimal in some of the ways we
talked about walks to work every day
he's into intermittent fasting he's
taking a lot of grief for that there's
no entourage at his house like he
everything is very not what you would
expect from somebody of that stature
yeah I think it's it's done in a way to
help him think about these big issues
without the clutter of you know the
day-to-day of what it must be like to
run like two of the biggest tech
companies yeah and in a Silicon Valley
culture of a lot of Burroughs who are
chasing the money like he just doesn't
strike me as that kind of person like I
feel like he's somebody we should root
for and he's flawed and doing the best
that he can and doing it very
imperfectly but like who would you
rather have helming this thing right now
and I'm not so sure I can think of
somebody I would swap out for Jack yeah
and I feel like a lot of these a lot of
these top impactful people who have
impacted multiple lives on this earth
through their ideas I think often times
they were just simply people who were
obsessed with solving a problem not and
and none of us you know remember the
fact that the invention of the ship was
also the invention
the shipwreck right and it's like you
know Twitter's solve some problems and
created new problems and whatever new
feature gets added in tomorrow to try to
promote empathy you know whether it's I
thought one woman to a presentation it
wasn't this year was last year was like
as you type up your comment like a
second window pops up and it shows is
this what you mean like hmm are you
meaning to say this person is just to
give you that extra moment
do ya lacked before you like do you
actually understand what you're about to
say to somebody and thinking that might
promote some more stuff and who knows
what can happen with that and you know
being in the YouTube universe and seeing
all the challenges that they're having
what censorship you know AI censorship
learning machines trying to figure out
how to catch inappropriate content or
violating content before it happens and
seeing people gain that system you know
watching somebody post a video that said
it was a video hanging my Gay Pride
shower curtain you know and then knowing
the words hanging and Gay Pride together
we're gonna get flagged right you know
and and now that the news will pick up
on that and be like oh you know signs of
homophobia in YouTube and we're always
realizing that someone's trying to
there's always somebody there just kind
of shooting shooting an arrow at you and
maybe being okay with that so part of
that is good though because a pressure
tests the systems and helps refine them
and at what point are we taking
responsibility like at what point you
know I think for me it definitely was
especially with Twitter was like all
right well I'm gonna decide who I follow
I don't follow and then one day you know
we started seeing posts from people that
you don't know and you're like oh rich
follows because somebody liked something
Oh sometimes it's not even light I'm
getting I'm getting features was like
you know rich follows so and so and I'm
just seeing that right yeah I see that
as well and I think it's them goes back
to that doubling down on that idea that
we need to keep your attention and if
you like his stuff then you might like
the stuff that he likes and it's just
kind of like hey here here are multiple
endless rabbit holes that you can fall
into we just need you to be here and at
the same time the cost of us all being
there is it's we're constantly exposed
to too much simulation where we're
constantly identifying the gaps in our
own life in relation to whatever we're
seeing so you know if I'm watching you
hiking with your shirt off and now
sudden I'm just like oh man I gotta stop
eating carbs like I got to get my body
weight down or or if I'm seeing you know
somebody publishing a book or doing a
book to a million oh I published my book
but I haven't done a book tour or having
done a signing in New York yet or
haven't done a signing in South Dakota
yet I need to make that happen and just
our minds going in all these different
places and the toll it takes on the
machine that is our brain yeah we don't
even have any grip I don't think yeah a
long term impact of this because you
have like a strategy for dealing with
this right now well I have to you know I
have to exert a lot of energy and to
create boundaries around it is I'm is
I'm an I'm an addict through and through
dude like this I don't you know if I
don't really create boundaries then you
know I'll get lost in this thing in the
way that I can use anything to try to
take me out of whatever emotional state
that I'm in at the moment so yeah it's
problematic for me like I have to put it
away and you know try not to check it in
the morning and especially you know as
as somebody who you know is a creator in
different ways
you can just occupy all of your free
time scrolling or passively consuming
other people's creativity and now more
than ever for perhaps the first time in
history like you have to really go to
the end of the earth to like remove
distractions so that you can do what
you're here to do and I'm finding it I
find it hard yeah so you don't check it
in the morning that's one I guess yeah I
think I wish I could say I'm perfect
about that but I certainly am NOT you
have to have buy an alarm I have rules
yeah you know yeah you have to have
rules from me I got a second phone and
then I learned from Neil
make make your main phone black and
white
great yeah it takes to take social media
off that first phone and the second
phone let that be your junk food phone
but don't
with you it works and then all of a
sudden I got to go on the trip I don't
want to carry two phones I put
everything on one and yeah back just
kind of laughs well it and that's the
thing there was there was a good Jay
Cole interview where he took a whole
year and a half off social media and
he's like I thought when I came back at
come with this new perspective and he
was like literally like eating a potato
chip again it's just like mmm it's as if
you never left and just start to see the
power like it's so salty and addictive
and it's uh it's such challenge because
it's everybody's in on it and
everybody's doing it and it's a it's
shaping it in and for us to exist you
know for people to know this podcast is
coming out you know they're probably
gonna find it on social media or in an
email list or or somebody else reposting
it and it's like it there's a beauty to
it and and there's a challenge to it
it's a it's a weapon and a tool in so
many different ways just like what you
were talking about with oneness and
unity yeah with one exactly inning is
all good or all bad nothing is all good
at all bad we are we are I mean we're a
piece of the puzzle we are also a puzzle
within the piece that we are and it's
just you know infinity on the outside
infinity on the inside and it's
remembering that perspective it kind of
helps us and in the next project I'm
dropping those both those concepts are
being explored to the fact that the
importance of zooming out from where we
are the game perspective and the
importance of zooming in mm-hmm you know
knowing that there isn't you don't just
do it once like you don't just achieve
balance and now you're a balanced and
you can just walk the tightrope forever
it's you got your balance and you lose
it then you have to regain it then you
lose it and obviously the longer you
focus on your balance you'll strengthen
your cores and you can do it for longer
but it doesn't get easier if we we
improve we get stronger and seeing that
you know sometimes thinking about it
gets daunting and then we have to just
remind ourselves that this doesn't all
have to get accomplished in a date you
know this can be a lifelong journey and
you know we under it we overestimate
what we can get done in a day
underestimate what we can get done in a
year I say that all the time and totally
underestimate well we know and
five years in ten years perfect example
being this book so 2014 we're now five
years later five years later and you're
really just starting to you know reap
the fruits of this labor it's been a
five year journey it's it's an and I
feel like I want to stress that you know
now I'm really doing the push and really
advocating for people to check it out
and open it and connect with it when I
wrote it I was my mind was somewhere
different it was oh if we're done yet so
now five years later they're like wait I
got to rewrite this this and this did
you revise it from I I wrote a new
forward which helped think encapsulated
I Redax that was when when I realized it
was gonna get it such a much larger
audience now I was like okay this five
years ago that that guy even know how to
write compared to like Who I am now do I
agree with these ideas and I went
through it and I was like oh this is
this is there you know there's a damn
timeless wisdom timeless wisdom but I
think more so like damn like you did a
really good job of trimming the fat like
you didn't you didn't over you didn't
over explain yourself you kept a simple
short and sweet and I mean this actually
represents a time when there was the
freedom of freedom of obscurity which I
want a lot of artists to embrace if you
were a brand new artists and nobody
knows who you are there is so much
freedom and being obscure because nobody
is looking at your stuff with a
magnifying glass and finding reasons to
critique it or to be offended or finding
holes or in your story and there was a
lot of freedom in writing this because
that guy who wrote this was in such a
different space and my only goals was to
continue writing until I felt better
because I wasn't feeling good about
myself and everything that I was coming
across wasn't working for me so I'd read
about like you know the author of Harry
Potter her name just slips me right now
JK Rowling JK Rowling and you know her
commencement speech where she talked
about you know rock bottom was the
foundation that I built myself up upon
and in my head I'd be like well how do I
know when I've hit rock bottom how do I
rebuild what was your rock bottom how
did you figure this all out your your
skipping steps in the story
I'm hearing was on welfare wrote you
know a universal international
bestseller in perspective time and
perspective and that but when you're
feeling the pain you just like give me
something for the pain right now give me
an an injection of validation give me an
injection of attention dopamine give me
anything give me some muscle relaxer
give me a shot
give me something to make it go away
right now I can't I can't stand this
anymore and I think now the perspective
has changed like I do I do dead Hanks
you know at the gym and from zero to ten
it's just getting getting there and then
from like ten seconds to about thirty
seconds it's like something's wrong with
my lung I can't breathe oh my god I'm
gonna die I better let go I better let
go and then telling my mind let's just
see what happens just like relax and
then passing that thirty five thirty
Seconds threshold and in like thirty to
a minute it's like I don't know I'm not
even aware of pain all of a sudden and
it's like kind of going through this
like dark tunnel and normally I would
just give up when I hit that first piece
of resistance and now realizing that
that's what it was it's it's what
happens once you pass that resistance
you know and the resistance is the
essential part of all of this
it's a beautiful allegory for the
dismantling and and kind of thing that
you went through yeah all completely in
a construction your divine moment and
that and that's what I'm bringing to the
table
I spent the time deconstructing this
because so many sources that I was
chasing with leaving me not feeling
satisfied like reading the quotes of you
know like don't worry
God has a plan God doesn't close the
door without opening a window and just
be like you yeah [ __ ] off like what the
[ __ ] does that mean
how is that gonna help me pay my
mortgage you know how is this gonna help
me get out of debt how is this gonna
help me find the courage to call my
buddy and be like I don't have your
money and then I got to the point where
I was realizing that you know I had
already given other people this advice
which was like I guess I said you're
making progress or you're making excuses
or sink or swim or you want you want
this to be easy go back to your job you
know you want you want results but
you're too scared to take that you're
too scared to take a shot you
you have to movement is your medicine
like these are these were revolutionary
ideas I had already heard them and just
it was easier for me to come to other
people not apply them to myself and I
took all these quotes and I plastered
them up in my room and my wall was just
full of non inspirational inspirational
quotes and there were just kicks in the
ass like suck it up deal with this you
know your problems may not be your fault
but your problems are your
responsibility and take ownership
you have the power for this anybody else
you blame you're just giving away the
problem you know pretty much saying you
know do this until you die and I think
that was the big one for me deciding
that I'm going to be humble the poet's
I've already been on with a poet long
enough at this point where I don't want
these constant reminders when people
recognize me that I failed this and
that's what that's what the apartment
building was seeing the condominium was
a reminder of my failures now realizing
no that was tuition I paid tuition to
get to where I was at so what's the
experience now when you drive by that
building oh we're good now you know
there's a there's a little bit of like
oh now you know that would have been
worth a lot of money if I still had it
but I had I had to give somebody back
some money when I sold it and they they
were very big on appearances I remember
they told me like hey if you need more
money I'll give you more money don't
sell your car we don't want people to
know you're struggling I didn't take
more money from them I got rid of the
car and then I didn't take more money
from them I got rid of the apartment and
then I paid them back and they said to
me I'm sorry yet to do that you know and
really kind of reminding me of how
embarrassing it was and I just caulk I
cockily said at that point like don't
worry eventually I'll have enough to buy
too and I'll be honest I had to get to
that point before it became comfortable
to look at that right and now I'm say
okay well yeah I might not be buying
that one now but you know I can I can
afford to you know buy one of these
pre-construction ones that are gonna
open in like twenty twenty four and I
can afford two of those no problem and
now I'm just starting over and that's
okay cuz I'm starting wiser and and I'm
more more patient more resilient I've
seen the story play out the seeds the
seed that I planted I didn't get to
decide when it was time for it to grow
and it's the same thing now even you
know
super fortunate to be on your podcast
and meet and meet your platforming and
your community of open-minded learners
who are trying to better themselves you
know this isn't something that every
author gets an opportunity of so
focusing on to gratitude and being like
it's cool and this time around the book
dropped on April 9th this time around it
wasn't I need to drop this book and I
need to hit the New York Times
bestsellers list for me to feel good
about myself
what it was was I need to make sure when
April 9th hits there isn't a voice in my
head that is telling me what I should
have done that I was too scared to do so
this time I reached out to every single
person I poked people more than I
Canadian sensibilities normally allowed
me to do I asked for the favors I tried
to make the deals I I i sent the book to
people that you know i would have been
too scared to bother i wasn't afraid to
burn bridges i just did everything i
could to make sure that this did
whatever it could do without expectation
of what it was going to do and knowing
that everybody that at that point that a
partner with had a very cautious
optimism towards of it but me knowing in
my heart and and learning from other
people you know the rock told lily this
and she told me you know he said listen
don't ever expect someone to give a [ __ ]
about your work as much as you do this
is your baby
don't expect them to care and don't hold
it against them if they don't because
this is yours and me being like okay
that's not my agents job it's not my
publishers job it's not my friends jobs
it's my job and i think it's the same
idea like you know if your car is it's
broken down on the side of the road you
know putting on your flashers and waving
that people might get you a certain
result but you'll get more results if
they see you pushing it and trying to
make something happen
and i think a lot of the support I've
gotten the immense immense support
beyond what I thought was going to
happen came from people seeing me work
and showing up and and and and being
wherever I needed to be and and telling
everybody hey you need me in your city
I'm there I don't I don't need you by my
can't expect them to be excited about it
if you're not exactly straighting that
level of excitement and I think a lot of
authors fall into this
sense that the publishers gonna do all
this stuff for them and you know I could
tell you that that is not the way it
goes it's like you really have to take
complete ownership of it and I think
because you came from that DIY
self-published you know experience you
were well equipped to you know really
take ownership of this new phase of what
the book presents for you completely it
was and it definitely it had I had this
opportunity arose two years ago or even
the year I published this book this
would have just fallen to obscurity I
wouldn't have been prepared I would have
sat back and thought oh you're with the
majors the majors handled it all this is
gonna be this is gonna be a hit this is
the next Eat Pray Love this gonna be the
next set of art this is gonna do that
and I think now this time it was like
know what you were given is a trampoline
that's all you're given and the
trampoline doesn't do anything unless
you got the legs to bounce it off and
you're only rewards and on this journey
or opportunities they're not outcomes
they're opportunities to work even
harder opportunities to do things so
work on things that you care about work
on things where the challenges are
exciting to tackle not things where
you're just like oh now not a nothing
you got to deal with work on things
where the resistance is exciting where
you're coming out of this a better
person and the personal growth I
experienced through again writing this
book when I when I saw published it I
had to build the book I had to choose
the font and I had to set the margins
and had to learn Adobe InDesign that
whole process is the real reward from
this not the money I made from this
getting the book to to the main stage
and getting it you know with one of the
three major publishers in the world and
having them you know say hey we've been
following you for a couple of years and
we were waiting for the right time to
make this happen and being like okay you
know this is great but this is also why
is this touching upon my why is this
touching upon my anxieties or why is
this touching upon my what's that called
when people think that they're they're
phony news item
imposter syndrome huh you know why you
know why is this either validating or
feeding my impossible imposter syndrome
and then that becoming okay well this is
something I have to write about and
realizing that hey you don't write to
publish books to sell books in the world
you write because you're a writer the
same reason why birds have something to
say and I what we all have something to
say and that's the important thing we
all have important stories each and
every one of us and our species has only
benefitted from people sharing their
stories and every single human being is
a potential innovator when provided with
experience wisdom access and education
and now all these tools we have can make
that grow at a exponential level and you
don't have to publish a book and get
validation from a major publisher you
can carve it on a cave-like like our
ancestors did you can put it in the
dance you can you can do it through your
photography you can do it in a poem you
can do it in any way shape or form never
knowing the impact that that's gonna
have but not view it even as a privilege
but as a responsibility and I think I
got to that point now we're like this is
my responsibility this is what I do I'm
not here for the validation of other
people I'm here to to live out my duty
in my service and then Sakhi we have the
concept of civil which is service and
learning that you know even every
successful business ever existed was
because they provided a service to the
people that they found value they found
value in and that had me changing my
language so I stopped saying please
support I'm not here to look for support
I'm not here to to like they're doing
you a favor
yeah don't do me a favor do yourself a
favor and get this book like I'm not
here to tap into people's empathy and
care about me if it's this is a
collection of what we've all been going
through in my contribution to this is my
ability to put words together the wisdom
that exists in here has it already will
exist in the reader it'll already be
there these are reminders you know that
this wisdom you're gonna find written by
you know Guru Nanak Dev ji and in the
late 1400s but you're also gonna find
this in you know Confucius you know
you're also gonna find this in some
Kanye West lyrics you're gonna find this
everywhere this isn't some secret
mystical stuff this is the stuff that
has to get repackaged for our generation
in the way we speak every chapters only
two pages because I recognize the
tension suspense
you know the book doesn't have to be
read and RAM generation this it is and
and that's that's also been a challenge
working with the publishers and saying
okay well we're here to to reach out to
the people you know who appreciate the
wellness space and let's connect with
people who do yoga let's connect people
and I was like I want to connect with
people who don't know that this stuff
matters yeah everybody you know not some
people don't realize that social media
is impacting them negatively on their on
their mental health
not everybody is realizing what why they
have anxiety they may not even have made
that simple connection that your
anxieties relate to your future and
maybe some of some of the older folks
have but you know some of the 18 year
olds and 19 year olds I'm talking to or
sometimes the ones that meet up my shows
are the ones I'm meeting at these these
YouTube conferences they don't know that
yet and and and the quicker we can get
them to recognize that and promote that
self-awareness then the quicker they can
move with more health and the quicker
they can pass that down as well because
if it took me 10 years to figure
something out
it should be my duty to help somebody
figure that out in five and
exponentially create that growth yeah so
I said every every chapter in this book
is two pages max you don't have to read
it in order I wanted it to be something
where you can just flip it open to any
random page you'll find a quote that you
dig and you'll find some that resonates
with you it's not going to be a long
read because books become investments
but you get it's so it's so easy to to
digest I mean just looking at the the
table kind like so you get anyone you've
liked 71 chapters 101 101 with 71 oh it
goes in the next yeah yeah it was a lot
yeah yeah and I mean yeah just there
were two random pages we go right let's
enjoy it we have well we have it and not
spend it worrying about a future we may
never see or an ending we can't avoid
it's another way of saying worry is
praying for the negative outcomes yeah
or you know worries like a rocking chair
yeah something to do but takes you know
where and if that's what my goal is is
this to really help people open
themselves up it's
what I was taught as a teacher is the
best teachers teach themselves out of a
job you know my goal isn't to keep you
coming back my goal is to help empower
you and then the challenge for me is
going to be okay I can't do the same
thing with the next book you know the
challenge for me is I got to go deeper
so now I have a community that I can go
on this journey I'm very fortunate that
I finished the other book before this
came out because the success of this
book would have totally crushed me with
the pressure and made me write something
completely different so I'm looking like
that perspective that you have that that
the gift is the opportunities that you
know come in the wake of it not like any
kind of you know measurable like
material outcome because the material
stuff lasts for a couple of hours and
literally like the happiness that comes
from it lasts for a couple of hours like
if you're gonna spend your money on
anything that you think will bring you
happiness at least making it an
experience you know travel somewhere
you'll still get some dopamine when you
rethink relive those experiences but you
buy yourself a Ferrari you might enjoy
it while you're driving it but if you're
if you're sitting at home just thinking
about it in the driveway it's not gonna
give you that value and eventually
you're gonna figure out your drive it's
just the car you drive and hi I operated
with a lot of chips on my shoulders
especially having a father was a cab
driver and knowing that he was
overqualified for that job and most cab
drivers in the City of Toronto are
overly educated and had no other
opportunities and one of my goals was to
put a Mercedes on our driveway and I did
I worked a second job and I bought a
nice c-class Mercedes and the goal was
like it's gonna make him so proud and so
happy he never sat in it once he really
refused so today I still don't know why
and I caught myself after being broken
up with a girl crying in the car and
being like what good is this you know
I'm still having my good days and bad
days but I'm just having it in this this
luxurious car that and there's the the
big point for me with I was working
extra hard to afford this wasn't in my
means when I had a surgery yeah if you
can afford it and as you know and it's
not a big deal than by all me your
perfect for Los Angeles mm-hmm everybody
stretch into like me car payments they
can't even do a car yeah
you know I think III feel like at that
this point now you know just you can
take a rideshare service if you can
afford one of these nice cars and you
can afford to have somebody else and do
that driving for you and it'll allow you
to get other things done but that chip
on my shoulder it came from my seeing my
father when I was four he got attacked
he was robbed and you know for the first
time seeing my father were like bumps
and bruises and cuts on his face at four
years old and he had to put a shield in
between his his his injure but that was
also our family car so when we went
places we went in the taxi with shield
and we're playing with the shield and
thinking all this but the older I got I
had these big chips on my shoulders to
like you know once I get that Mercedes
it's gonna make that worth it once I
make enough money I'm gonna retire my
dad whatever projecting onto him that he
had that same sensibility yeah and these
these weren't things that he care about
or he never discussed you know like that
robbery is not something he ever brought
up again you know I think he just
adjusted he's just like alright got
robbed in the middle of the night I'm
not working at night no more let me work
6:00 a.m. to 6:00 p.m. like let me make
certain changes and and then they
eventually moved from driving taxi in
the city to driving taxi at the airport
which was a whole different level of
clientele who were taking these limos
from the from the airport so I think he
made his adjustments accordingly I don't
think he really grew up in an
environment that promoted much self-pity
is to adjust adapt adjust or you're
gonna die how are they now with you um
everything you're doing it's it's if
it's funny its evolving its evolving I
mean again when hearing in comparison to
other people especially you know
children of immigrant and children of
immigrants and hearing their stories in
comparison to mine my parents were great
they they definitely did not have the
tools to have a son like me they had
never heard they don't know any artists
they didn't know any creatives I still
don't know from you know who amongst my
family passed down any creative genes
and my way they didn't foster creativity
with me they didn't promote it but they
didn't sure there were probably some
amazingly creative people that just had
to repress that impulse their whole life
so you're not even a
err of where they fall in your lineage
yeah 1,000% however in sick heritage all
the hymns rhyme you know so like so
Czestochowa just sochi luck vlog to pick
up noisy light-hearted lift odd like it
all rhymes so i was force-fed all the
hymns as a kid to memorize that was the
knob my novelty trick being an
eight-year-old kid who memorized an hour
worth of hymns and they all rhymed so I
was always rhyming and then we would
sing them on harmonium so I was also
taught how to sing and I was also taught
up a double ax so I was given all the
tools I needed to be a rapper I was
taught how to rhyme I was taught rhythm
I played percussion and in middle school
I played the steel pan because I grew up
in a heavy Caribbean neighborhood so I
was playing steel pan so I was playing
instruments but none of this was this
was all like extracurricular activities
are part of my school part of my
schooling are part of my parents
religious education upon me and it gave
me all those necessary skills as well as
I said the gurus you know they mobilized
they ran armies and and some of the Sikh
temples and the goldwater in Toronto
they post pictures of who they
considered martyrs people that fought in
the struggles and in the eighties
specifically so being a little kid I'm
looking at pictures of dead bodies
hanging on the walls so our you know my
relationship with violence was a little
bit different so then when one of the
kids the local kids in my neighborhood
like played NWA for me you know it was
like these guys rhyme and they kill and
like this is no different than some of
the things you're staying connection
yeah because for me it was because when
I first got into this I would you know
people would be like you're not black
why are you rapping like you do you have
an identity crisis and I was like this
is this is my heritage since I first
started it's just I'm doing it in
English because both my parents had to
work when I when I was a child and my
grandparents weren't there so like they
put me in daycare when I was 2 years old
so I wasn't speaking the mother tongue
at home I was speaking English because I
was in daycare with everybody else and
had two older sisters to speak English
with whereas they were raised by my
grandparents and they were watching the
films and everything else so my my
upbringing was a little bit different so
my parents they never got in the way
other than comments
and when I when I made the when I made
the leave when I left teaching they saw
how much I was already kind of working
at this and I think they realized that
we can't really stop him if we wanted to
when I came home after you know what my
tail between my legs and my head down as
I said they they gave me a little bit of
a verbal spanking and I deserved it I
needed it I needed to be held
accountable I wasn't blind as I said I
wasn't manipulated by a master I wasn't
blindsided but beyond that it was just
kind of like it will stay out of your
way
figure it out my mother much more vocal
so like every year after that she'll I
go back to work go back to work like why
don't you go back to work
you know I'm are you making any money
think cool things would happen Lee I got
on like my name was printed on the cover
of Rolling Stones India and that was a
big deal for me I had them shipped me
copies and I was like showing my mom and
she's like but are you making any money
right obviously you're not making any
money from me having your name on a
magazine and let's don't pay you for
that they don't pay you for that or like
if I get a gig sometimes you get a gig
worth like it'll you know they might pay
for your ticket they might give you like
a thousand bucks but it's not enough to
make a full living off of and she'll be
like what are you saving are you making
enough you know you I think you've had
your fun just go back to your job well
they take you back well you were your
principal taking back and I did go back
III in 2013 when I was losing hope I
didn't go back and my principal just
said to me hey you have a spot here you
can cut it wasn't July I went and she's
like hey you have a spot here in
September if you want it'll be very
challenging for me to shuffle around the
staff it'd be much easier if you came
back in January are you cool with that
no thing yeah yeah yeah I'm only coming
back because I missed the kids like yeah
I don't need the money yeah I'll come
back in January then I left her office
be like you're not going back yeah like
you you better be now you got to go back
and just talk to the kids
yeah it's if yeah that's been a that's
been a challenging thing in the
beginning I couldn't face that school
because again there was another source
of failure I felt in the beginning now
there was actually one of my more recent
music videos I had a method actress and
I had her in the music video not
realizing that I I went to school with
her older sister and her older sister
used to come used to come to the school
I taught at to pick up her little
brother
so that little brother had grown up and
he had recently been murdered and that
opened up a lot for me in terms of life
that I had banned in my community that I
just forget about everyone and moved to
LA and then it became a new challenge
like that and then it's kind of like you
stopped picking up somebody's calls for
so long you don't know if you can just
kind of pick it up and go back and if
you're gonna recognize anything and so
that is definitely one of the challenges
some of the old teachers have come to
events that I've thrown and I've stayed
in contact with them that way I think
most of the staff is kind of like where
I'm from in Ontario is going through a
lot of challenges we have Rob that's
your growth opportunity that isn't my
growth opportunity and I have to lean
into that and that's something that just
recently happened and it was a again it
was one of those perspective shifts for
me to is like what are you what are you
doing this all for what really is it
like you can get and that's what I have
to keep asking myself like you can tell
you can say the nice things for the
podcast and you can say oh I care about
helping people I care about this but
then why did you extend your trip two
weeks why did you go to that premiere
why did you make sure you got that
picture with so-and-so on the red carpet
why did you do all these things and what
how is that helping like real real
shit's happening back at home the real
[ __ ] that you are extremely fortunate to
get out of my neighborhood I'm from
wreck still in Toronto if you're from
Toronto you know the reputation that
Rexel has and I grew up on I didn't grow
up in the most challenging part of it
but I went to school and definitely the
most challenging part of it and I taught
and another challenging part of that
that area and I was teaching kids who
were witnessing shootings I was teaching
kids who were witnessing a lot of
violence and what am i doing to help
that what can I do to help them and also
figuring out whether it's you know using
my celebrity to poke at the local city
councillor to make sure the jungle gym
is safe like I have scars on my legs
from injuries I sustained on broken
jungle gyms in the neighbourhood and
such is accordingly like well and I know
I can you know and thinking out loud
well you know and
time I know I can do more to have that
impact and it's kind of like yeah you
said you look at like
Nipsey Hussle and like what he was doing
in his community it's kind of inspiring
to think of you know the power and the
responsibility of someone like yourself
with respect to your community exactly
and I had just connected with him in the
middle of March Wow I had tweeted at him
and he had followed me back and I sent
him a long message and I promised myself
that was flying to India for a show and
in India straight here and I said all
right you are going to find him
you were you were and you were not gonna
take no for an answer you're gonna learn
as much as you can because he's very big
on ownership and he's very big on
independence and taking the slow route
and I was I was dealing with challenges
of with my publishers I mean and every
time I heard him speaking like man maybe
I shouldn't what the major is like he
didn't you know I need to learn this
from him and now that I have he follows
me I have at least one direct line to
reach out to him I'm just gonna go to
his store I'm just gonna camp out and
I'm just like I'll risk getting beat up
to get this knowledge and then the
flight back from India I was Mumbai to
to Frankfurt and Frankfurt to LA and
then Frankfurt I got the news and then
it was a lot of crying in the bathroom
it was it was it was a that would that
was yeah that really that a lot of I
think I do need just some time to like
really figure this out and but
definitely we as a learning community me
as a hip-hop artist me as somebody who
embraces that culture this is our
opportunity to magnify who he was you
know we get to decide now if we're gonna
just call Eliseo he inspired us or this
is our opportunity to be like all right
let's do what he trans like that and
translate that and I think probably and
it was a discussion I had with some of
my friends were Somali because they're
all first-generation they were all born
in Somalia and then they came here at
like five six years old and they're all
like no we're just working making our
money and we're going back like we're
taking this all back and I'm like what
about your kids your kids interested in
some money they're like no
like see I'm your kids generation and
I'm a minority over there - I'm a
minority back in India - and I'm a
minority here and I don't know I don't
what is my community in my community
actually is the neighborhood I grew up
in and having to support that in some
way shape or form and whether that's got
to be being on these big platforms and
shouting out the city and shouting
artists or whether it's building better
jungle gyms or whether it's getting
involved in politics on a local level
it's a challenge and it's a tricky thing
to do but I'm working on it I've you
know I got I've gotten a seat at a table
I think Toronto might be the only city
right now that will give a guy like me a
seat at the table and I've been given a
seat at the table and at the same time
I'm still going to some of these Street
guys mixtape release parties and getting
a lot of love and trying to exist in the
entire spectrum and trying to pass down
the education I'm learning from you know
these these top CEOs and business minds
and trying to apply that to to these
young entrepreneurs who are wasting
their money on Gucci belts and stuff
like that
trying to figure out a way to share that
with them without sounding preachy well
I think you've earned your seat at the
table and I feel like you're just
beginning like I feel like I've caught
you here today like the the very early
stages and what you're gonna create I'm
excited to see what that is well thank
you I hope I hope that's the case I hope
it's a you know for years and years to
come you can be like you know I was
messing with humble before it was cool
pretty cool out there in the world at
the moment you know again I'm nothing
but gratitude for you for again sharing
this with me you were you're a super
dope dude and I said I you know I met I
met your partner at the market angel
event right and that's what kind of
first introduced me and she was sharing
some of your story and then that kind of
introduced me to this world and I'm so
grateful that this world exists where
there's just a lot of people trying to
better themselves in real time and
sharing their notes with a lot of other
people who are trying to better
themselves and I feel like it's just
going to be an exponential thing we're
all on this
we're all in it together elegantly
trying to figure it out good rent
thank you so much for having so cool uh
really great to talk to you man
really appreciate it the book is
unlearned 101 simple truths for a better
life and you can find it
every word you find it everywhere you
got a website for it though right tea is
people go to your the website to get it
I mean and I'll help them find the you
know their preferred spot so humble the
poet calm slash unlearn but I mean we're
on Amazon Barnes & Noble all the
independent bookstores I mean now that
it's been doing so well in Amazon from
what the publishers are telling me it's
getting on more shelves somebody told me
that they went to Barnes & Noble inside
of the side of the front of the store
oh yeah nicely a big deal so I'm happy
about that and even just if you check it
out just literally open it to any page
you're gonna find sorry you know find a
quote this quote right here heart breaks
like any other struggle is essential for
your growth this is my old teacher way
to show them the picture and every once
in a while you'd read it and you switch
the page like mr.singh you've been the
show-off the picture you get to sit
there in the scan the whole room and you
just watch them absorb it so and I've
been doing YouTube videos now reading
from the book and being masculine
telling the kids to shut up and sit down
that's right it's been fun but um ya
know thank you so much for again again
sharing a platform for me I do have a
question for you
just for my own selfish personal growth
what is the challenge that you are
currently excited to tackle in your own
journey right now I got a bunch of them
right now is it one I mean I'm trying to
get I'm trying to crack another book
wide open okay moment and that's been
difficult not only on the ideation
aspect of it but also just on the
scheduling aspect because my life is so
much more full and busy yeah than it was
when I wrote my first book where I had a
lot more time and not a lot going on and
not a lot of emails and people calling
me you know and now it's different so it
goes back to what we were talking about
about like look you know having
boundaries around your
and how you're exercising you know those
precious hours during the day to make
sure that they're channeled in the
direction of what can move the needle
the most you know and it's been a while
since I've written anything so that's my
mountain to climb this year that I'm
excited about but also scared and
intimidated and all of that and were you
at right now look at the outlining
process yeah yeah early days my friend
early days I I had for the next one that
I that I'm releasing I spent a whole
summer and I set the goal of a thousand
words a day mmm he's like oh you needs
to be seventy thousand yeah all right
cool I can get this done in the summer
and then the entire draft had to get
scrapped did it it's easy to look at
that and think about was wasted time but
that's those are the push ups those are
the reps yeah you know they are you a
better writer and that's me leaving one
space you know spending more time in a
digital world and the traditional
publishing world and realizing I hate
this is these people aren't impressed by
my cute little Instagram captions they
really want to bring out the best in me
and yeah that's actually what when I
when I sign with Harper that was the
only promise my agent said to me was I'm
not promising you you're gonna become an
international sensation but I am
promising you you'll leave this better
writer because these editors and think
they're not forgiving that yeah they're
really gonna poke you poke at you until
they get they get the good stuff and
that was a process and a half so it is
fun
or maybe I'm saying it's fun cuz I'm
done yeah but it's humbling it is my
deadline was November first yeah my
deadline was November first and I
finished at the end of February for
perspective I got you right and I'm like
oh yeah here we are so that you know
when I dropped that that would be a fun
one too cool so check out the book if
you want to learn more about humble
check out the show notes I'll put a
bunch of links up there and you're easy
to find on the internet just out humble
the poet pretty much everywhere YouTube
Instagram
instagrams your main Jam these days
right Instagram and Twitter
yeah I'm mama I like I like being on
Twitter Twitter's fun Instagram and
trying to try to put some oxygen back in
Facebook and are you doing any concerts
or live events or anything like that
where people can
learn you know come see you I'm gonna be
in New Jersey on the 9th of May at the
at the indigo store they made their move
into the states that's their first
location I'm gonna check that out and I
am currently working on a couple of
other bookstores in other cities but one
thing that will definitely do is a lot
of local media in whatever city so I
think I think I'm looking at green apple
and in San Francisco trying to secure a
date there maybe Powell's and Portland
really pushing the independent
bookstores because independent
bookstores matter and I really want to
get out there meet some more book nerds
and sign some books all right man we'll
come back and talk to me again sometime
for sure all right peace my friend yes
[Music]